voilà sinon à quand la rupture
énergétique et bien j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous c'était il y a 500000
ans et voilà donc on s'en fout et vous
pouvez aller dîner en fait la rupture la
première rupture énergétique est arrivée
pour les hommes la première fois que ils
ont découvert une source d'énergie
extracorporelle et ça c'est avec la rose
phare la découverte plus exactement du
feu nous sommes sauf erreur de ma part
une des très rares espèces à être
capable de faire appel à des sources
d'énergie extracorporelles et la
première fois que ça nous est arrivé
c'était il y a 500 000 ans donc la
transition énergétique pour notre espèce
c'est quelque chose qui dure depuis très
très longtemps vous étiez pas encore né
que ça existait déjà et ça va
probablement encore durer très très
longtemps loi de transition ou pas loi
de transition
le
la manière dont je vais rentrer dans le
sujet normalement devrait vous permettre
d'oublier quelques petits soucis de la
vie quotidienne donc par exemple pour
tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont
horripilés quand ils doivent attendre
que leur smartphone répondent ou qui ont
déjà attendu dans un restaurant
s'énervement beaucoup ou qui n'aime pas
que les transports en commun et du
retard chose que je vois de temps en
temps voilà donc j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous j'ai aussi une mauvaise durée
c'est la même normalement dans une heure
vous devriez penser que tout ça n'a
strictement aucune espèce d'importance
voilà donc je vais ce soir être le
médecin des armes vous amenez beaucoup
de réconfort
en vous amenant à relativiser je
l'espère énormément de choses
j'ai coutume de dire que un débat c'est
un vrai débat quand c'est au 20 heures
de TF1
à débat national c'est ça ma définition
c'est un débat national quand c'est au
20 heures de TF1 tant que les gens
n'entendent pas parler dans les médias
de masse on va dire que c'est quelque
chose qui concerne les gens qui ont
envie de se faire plaisir ou des
spécialistes mais c'est pas ce qu'on
appelle un débat national alors il se
trouve que quand on a un débat sur
l'énergie en général ça prend des formes
qui sont pas du tout les explications
patientes apaisées et la recherche de
solutions ça ressemble plutôt à ça
et soit dit en passant vous pouvez
transposer cette manière de vous
approprier les débats sur l'énergie à
tout parce que ça marche aussi avec le
pétrole ça marche aussi avec le charbon
et ça marche même avec l'éolien d'accord
donc tous les débats énergétiques ils
ont quand on les voit du grand public et
que vous regardez un sujet au 20 heures
de TF1 en fait ce que vous allez voir
arriver le vrai débat grand public c'est
je suis pour je suis contre voilà
c'est évidemment un tout petit peu plus
subtil que cette affaire malheureusement
comme la classe politique j'y reviendrai
pas à la fin de cette exposé mais il y
aura vraiment des questions qui tournent
autour de que fait la police comme la
classe politique s'informe
essentiellement d'une manière remontante
en lisant la presse le 80% de ce qui
fait la réaction d'un personnage
politique c'est ce qu'il y avait dans le
journal la veille et bien en gros quand
il y a un débat dans ce pays il a une
fâcheuse tendance à obéir à la maxime
Shadok que voici qui est
quand on ne sait pas où on va de toute
façon l'important c'est d'y aller plus
vite possible et il faut rendre hommage
à Nicolas Hulot d'avoir très récemment
rappelé que il y avait peut-être une
autre manière de prendre les problèmes
c'est à dire d'essayer de classer dans
l'ordre d'essayer de se donner un plan
de marche qui ne conduise pas à quelque
chose de frontalement impossible parce
que en fait on a parlé sans réfléchir et
malheureusement j'aurais pas le temps de
tous les aborder ce soir mais pour ceux
d'entre vous à qui il reste quelques
sester
j'ai fait un petit florilège partiel
parce que il y en a beaucoup plus que ce
que j'ai dans mon bouquin de quelques
malentendus qui depuis que je
m'intéresse à ces affaires là donc la
première fois que j'ai trempé dans un
débat national sur l'énergie c'est en
2003 pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont
suffisamment vieux passés dans cette
salle et c'est une très bonne nouvelle
parce que d'habitude j'ai un peu trop de
retraité dans les gens qui viennent
m'écouter
il m'intéresse pas les retraités ils
font plus rien de leur vie terminés
passent aux jeunes donc bah oui donc il
vote quand même mais bon à part ça donc
le
en 2003 donc il y a eu un débat national
sur l'énergie on est les plus jeunes ne
se souviennent pas il y a eu un comité
consultatif et je me suis retrouvé
bombardé président de ce comité
consultatif donc ça a été ma première
immersion dans ce sujet là et j'ai
remarqué que la quasi-totalité des
débats dit grand public donc ceux qui
sont au 20h de TF1 ils fonctionnent à
l'envers c'est à dire que d'abord on
s'écharne on s'échappe pardon sur est-ce
que je suis pour est-ce que je suis
contre et peut-être qu'un jour
éventuellement vous expliquera de quoi
il s'agit
si vous avez de la chance complètement
sûr
là où je vais en venir ce soir puisque
on m'a posé la question à quand la
rupture alors j'ai une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle là aussi c'est la même
elle arrivera de toute façon vous savez
que il y a un grand sujet en ce moment
qui passionne beaucoup de gens qui
s'appelle le changement climatique et le
grand jeu en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique c'est d'être
capable de fonctionner en arrêtant
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre pas
loin un tout petit peu et arrêter
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre il y
a une abréviation maintenant qui est
passée dans le langage courant qui
consiste à dire être bas carbone c'est
ça arrêtez d'émettre des gaz à effet de
serre alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
absolument tout le monde va devenir bas
carbone un jour soit parce qu'on le veut
ou soit précisément parce qu'on ne veut
pas
un peu plus tard alors je vais essayer
de reprendre le problème à la racine et
je vais prendre quelqu'un non pas qui
parle à 300 personnes en enfuisant 200
mais qui parle à 6 millions de personnes
enfin maintenant il est à la retraite
mais qui parlait à 6 millions de
personnes donc je vous présente l'homme
qui a été le prof le plus connu de
France et de très très loin pendant les
quelques années où il officiait à qui
veut gagner des Millions pardon pas de
pub
j'ai jamais réussi à faire en sorte que
il pose cette question soit dit en
passant j'aurais bien aimé j'avais
essayé de convaincre sans grand succès
les gens de TF1 de poser des questions
sur l'environnement de temps en temps
puisque en fait quand cet homme-là
posait une question vous aviez 6
millions de personnes derrière qui
connaissaient la réponse s'il y aurait
pu poser des questions sur
l'environnement ça aurait fait de la
formation un peu de frais mais peu
importe imaginons qu'il pose cette
question d'après vous l'énergie c'est
quoi alors à vous qui êtes dans cette
salle je pense qu'une partie connaît
déjà la réponse mais si je prends des
gens que je croise au hasard dans la rue
par le conducteur de métro qui m'a amené
ici je parle à la personne charmante au
demeurant qui me vend mes fruits et
légumes je parle à la personne qui est
en train de balayer les feuilles en
cette saison etc c'est quoi pour vous
l'énergie
la probabilité que il réponde ce à quoi
je pense et à peu près nul proche de
zéro ce qui va leur venir à l'esprit
instantanément à part les débats que
vous avez déjà vu c'est à dire c'est les
gens du nucléaire et de l'éolien qui se
tapent dessus ça va être ça
le rapport quotidien que moi j'ai avec
l'énergie c'est de temps en temps je
reçois une facture voilà c'est comme ça
qu'ils vont immédiatement prendre le
problème donc l'énergie c'est une
facture d'électricité c'est une facture
de gaz si vraiment vous réfléchissez
bien et que vous n'êtes pas trop pressé
vous allez mettre le plein d'essence
dedans c'est vrai ça rater là d'accord
donc l'énergie c'est un truc que je paye
alors le drame quand on commence à
répondre ça c'est qu'on a perdu c'est
qu'on a perdu parce que ça coûte pas
cher vous avez ici trois courbes qui
vous donnent pour le monde dans son
ensemble ce que coûte l'énergie
rapportée à ce que les gens gagnent
alors la totalité de ce que les gens
gagnent c'est ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le PIB j'y reviendrai un peu
plus tard dans cette exposé mais le PIB
c'est par définition en comptabilité la
valeur de la totalité de ce que vous
vendez et du coup comme on ne paye que
des hommes j'y reviendrai aussi c'est la
totalité de ce que les gens gagnent soit
en salaire soit en rente affreux
actionnaires qui se prennent une partie
du gâteau mais c'est ça c'est la
totalité de vos revenus et donc ce que
vous dépensez pour acheter de l'énergie
que vous voyez là et bien c'est ce que
vous coûte l'énergie votre rapport à
l'énergie c'est juste de payer une
facture alors vous voyez les très très
mauvaises années c'est monté à 10% de ce
que les gens gagnaient ça s'est appelé
les chocs pétroliers les chocs
pétroliers récents on était plutôt à la
moitié et si je prends une période hors
choc pétrolier que je mets tous à vous
bah bonhomme allant ça me coûte quelques
pourcents de ce que je gagne
voilà ce que je gagne on s'en fout nos
[ __ ] parce que à partir du moment où
vous vous dites l'énergie c'est quelques
pourcents de ce que je gagne et bien le
réflexe logique que vous allez avoir
juste derrière c'est ça vaut le coup de
m'en occuper quelques pourcents du temps
il reste du temps je m'en fous je
m'occupe de sujets sérieux ce qu'on va
faire avec les retraites avec l'école
avec je sais pas quoi la paix dans le
monde bon bref le reste du temps je m'en
fous
alors ce raisonnement en fait à cause du
fait que l'énergie est un déterminant de
tout le reste c'est à peu près aussi
raisonnable ou intelligent que si vous
disiez votre cervelle c'est 2% de votre
poids donc ça suffit de l'oxygéner de %
du temps le reste du temps vous en
foutez complètement ou bien si je vous
enlève la moitié et bien vous serez 1%
moins efficace c'est pas très grave
survivrai assez facilement c'est
exactement le même raisonnement et
pourquoi c'est le même raisonnement
parce que on va voir dans pas longtemps
que l'énergie pilote le reste vous avez
le même genre de raisonnement totalement
stupide en économie quand on vous dit
l'agriculture c'est 2% du PIB donc on
s'en fout enfin si je vous empêche de
manger pendant suffisamment longtemps je
pense que le reste du PIB va commencer à
flageoler un peu
donc ces raisonnements on part de
camembert dans lesquels on comprend pas
qu'il y a une part du camembert qui
pilote les autres parts sont des
raisonnements inopérants vous en sortez
rien enfin si vous en sortez des bêtises
quand vous passez à l'action mais sinon
vous n'en sortez rien
donc mon ami Foucault a posé la question
a qui n'est pas la bonne réponse après
vous avez un deuxième réflexe pavlovien
aujourd'hui chez les gens qui s'occupent
d'énergie qui est de dire je sais pas
trop ce que c'est que l'énergie mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
l'économiser car vous savez comme moi
que la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on
ne consomme
que moi deuxième mauvaise réponse si
vous êtes dans cette salle c'est
justement parce qu'on n'a pas économiser
l'énergie
si on avait économisé l'énergie c'est à
dire si on n'avait pas commencé à se
vautrer dans les combustibles fossiles
parce que votre luxure et bien au lieu
d'être ici à m'écouter vous seriez
éreintés chez vous dans votre chaumière
après une journée à ramasser les patates
voilà ce que vous feriez il y aurait pas
les machines qui aurait bossé pour vous
toute la journée pour vous faire vos
vêtements les fauteuils sur lesquels
vous êtes assis vous êtes assis pardon
par assis heureusement sauf pour
certains d'entre vous moi inclus
le métro qui vous a amené ici la salle
dans laquelle nous sommes et qui a été
construite très rapidement etc tout ça
ça n'existerait pas sans énergie
abondante donc on serait toujours une
civilisation agraire et alors qui est
vous seriez éreinté vautré sur votre lit
que vous auriez toutes les chances de
partager avec vos enfants
voilà ça serait ça donc la raison pour
laquelle vous êtes aujourd'hui dans
cette salle avec le temps de venir
écouter mais ça en est c'est justement
parce que nous n'avons pas économiser
l'énergie
alors ça veut pas dire qu'à l'avenir
c'est pas un sujet ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est que quand on dit la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas c'est une appréciation
relative
c'est pas une règle absolue au regard de
ce qui a été l'histoire des hommes alors
l'essentiel des gens soit dit en passant
dans strictement aucune idée sur la
question à part les deux premières
quand en 2003 perd son arme enfin je
sais pas où elle est maintenant j'ai
dépendu une mise de l'énergie de
l'époque dans le débat national je pense
qu'elle est rentrée dans le débat est
sortie du débat en sachant toujours pas
ce que c'était qu'un kilowattheure
donc il y a énormément de gens qui ne
savent pas du tout ce que c'est que
l'énergie ça les ennuie pas du tout soit
dit en passant ils ont l'impression
qu'ils vivent très bien ça
et puis vous pouvez demander un poète et
le poète va vous donner la bonne réponse
le poète va vous dire l'énergie c'est ce
qui me permet d'agir sur le monde alors
la version très poétique c'est un matin
où je suis en forme je suis plein
d'énergie le poète a raison c'est plus
exactement si je suis plein d'énergie je
me sens en forme ça veut dire quoi être
plein d'énergie ça veut dire être plein
d'une capacité à influer sur le monde et
à influer sur votre destin
parce que l'énergie en physique
l'énergie est une grandeur physique
avant d'être quoi que ce soit d'autre
l'énergie c'est donc soumis à des lois
qui ne dépendent pas de nous c'est ça
qui est très désagréable et c'est ça que
Monsieur Brotte quand il a fait voter sa
loi de transition juste un peu oublié il
a pensé que la loi des hommes pouvait
s'imposer aux lois physiques et quelques
doutes sur la validité de ce genre de
Paris
donc en fait l'énergie c'est par
définition ce qui caractérise la
transformation du monde c'est ça ça
définition l'énergie c'est ce qui
caractérise tout ce qui quantifie plus
exactement la transformation du monde
donc de l'énergie va entrer en jeu dès
que vous allez modifier une température
une forme une vitesse une couleur
n'importe quoi dès que vous avez une
transformation dans le monde qui vous
entoure vous avez de l'énergie qui est
entre en jeu donc plus vous êtes capable
de mobiliser d'énergie parce qu'on va
voir derrière qu'en fait vous la
consommez pas personne dans cette salle
ne voit le pétrole enfin je vous le
conseille pas c'est pas terrible donc
dès que vous êtes capable de mobiliser
de l'énergie en fait vous êtes capable
d'influer sur votre destin et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les hommes ont
cherché en utiliser de plus en plus tant
qu'il y avait pas de limites à au
système qu'ils étaient en train de
manipuler
alors je vais parler un tout petit peu
physique je suis désolé je vais employer
quelques gros mots vos souvenirs
scolaires puisque vous êtes jeune pour
l'essentiel d'entre vous sont moins
anciens que les miens donc les souvenirs
vont être plus désagréables ça va être
plus douloureuse ça va faire un peu mal
mais vraiment désolé donc la physique
joue un rôle majeur dans l'énergie
puisque l'énergie est une grandeur
physique alors en physique vous avez une
grande loi
doit absolument majeur qui n'est pas dû
aux gens de chez Bonduelle la loi de
conservation
pendant de ce jeu de mouiller nul et la
loi de conservation elle vous dit
quelque chose d'extrêmement simple elle
vous dit que quand vous êtes dans un
système qui ne communique pas avec
l'extérieur l'énergie se conserve
c'est ça la loi de conservation c'est
très très simple d'accord donc à
l'intérieur d'un système qui ne
communique pas avec le reste vous ne
pouvez ni créer ni détruire de l'énergie
c'est vraiment très très simple alors
prenez l'humanité tant que l'humanité ne
communique pas avec l'extérieur elle ne
peut pas créer d'énergie et donc en fait
ce qu'on appelle utiliser de l'énergie
c'est l'extraire de l'environnement où
elle existe déjà
toute énergie que nous utilisons sur
terre absolument toutes y compris notre
propre alimentation est une énergie qui
vient de l'environnement où elle
préexiste déjà
c'est tout ce qu'on a le droit de faire
d'accord sinon on viole la première loi
de la thermos qui est quand même un peu
ennuyeux
alors dans les temps anciens pardon et
cette énergie vous allez la faire
rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle la
convertisseur c'est à dire une machine
qui va la prendre sous la forme sous
laquelle elle absorbe et en faire autre
chose alors si la machine c'est vous
vous rentrez l'énergie sous forme
chimique c'est l'énergie contenue dans
les aliments et vous allez en faire deux
choses de la chaleur parfaitement
renouvelable votre corps à 37 degrés et
un peu de mouvement pas beaucoup en fait
si vous regardez en pas relative dans
l'énergie qui sort de votre corps c'est
essentiellement de la chaleur si vous
étiez des reptiles ce qui est peut-être
la pensée qui vous vient à l'esprit pour
quelqu'un de vos voisins désagréable et
bien vous auriez besoin de 10% seulement
de l'énergie que vous utilisez parce que
vous n'auriez pas besoin de maintenir
votre corps à une température constante
voilà le corollaire c'est quand il fait
froid soyez tout le temps pâté et
incapable de travailler
alors au début donc le seul
convertisseur auquel les hommes ont eu
accès c'était eux-mêmes
donc moi on me rentre de la nourriture
dans le Gargamel et je suis capable d'en
ressortir donc de la chaleur du
mouvement et autres voilà puis de la
chaleur du moment
avec le temps
quelques brillants ingénieurs
ont trouvé d'autres convertisseurs
énergétiques capable d'utiliser d'autres
sources d'énergie que les hommes encore
une fois ne peuvent pas exploiter en
direct parce que je le redis boire du
pétrole en direct c'est pas terrible
manger du charbon en direct sauf
flatulence c'est pas conseillé respirer
du gaz en direct sauf l'hélium pour
avoir la voix de Mickey c'est pas
terrible non plus donc en fait les
énergies que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
quand un franc on dit un Français
consomme du pétrole non il consomme pas
de pétrole le français pas au sens où il
le voit quand un Français consomme du
pétrole en fait il mobilise à son profit
une machine qui consomme du pétrole
c'est ça qui fait en vérité
donc il faut deux choses pour que on
augmente la consommation d'énergie il
faut d'une part que on est inventé le
convertisseur qui permet de s'en servir
et d'autre part il faut que on diffuse
le nombre de convertisseurs qui s'en
servent
et à ce moment on peut utiliser puis
bien sûr il faut que l'énergie préexiste
dans l'environnement du coup je vais
vous proposer à partir de maintenant
même si ça va vous demander un petit
exercice de gymnastique difficile pour
l'esprit et il est tard de remplacer à
chaque fois que j'utiliserai
consommation d'énergie que je vais
essayer d'utiliser le moins souvent
possible
utilisation de machines et donc
augmenter sa consommation d'énergie en
fait ce que vous devez comprendre c'est
j'augmente le parc de machines dont je
suis en train de me servir directement
ceux qui sont en train de taper sur leur
smartphone au lieu de m'écouter c'est
pas bien
les quelques caméras qui tournent etc et
surtout indirectement parce que quand
vous avez enfilé un vêtement ce matin
vous avez indirectement mobilisé à votre
profil des milliers de machines
tout ce qui va du puits de pétrole
jusqu'au vêtements si c'est du poly
machin chouette et tout ce qui va du
champ jusqu'au vêtements si c'est du
coton ou du lin
je peux vous dire qu'il y a des milliers
de machines qui ont bosser pour que vous
enfiliez vos vêtements le matin
alors ces machines elles nous ont permis
de devenir des surhommes pour de vrai
donc monsieur Nietzsche en voulait nous
voici
et je vais vous montrer ça avec un petit
calcul très simple qui va comparer
l'énergie mécanique capable de sortir de
vos jambes les vôtres pas les plus
musclés sur terre et ce que une machine
est capable de nous fournir alors je
vais vous prendre vous avec vos jambes
et là c'est un exercice je suis sûr il y
a plein de gens dans la salle parce que
vous êtes jeune et en bonne santé qui
l'ont fait et qui sont encore capables
de le faire je vous mets un petit sac à
dos sur le dos et je vous fais monter
2000 mètres de dénivelé donc je sais pas
je vous fais monter 5 fois la tour
Montparnasse doit faire à peu près 200 m
sans prendre l'ascenseur sinon vous
trichez et après vous aurez un peu faim
mais vous n'aurez pas volé votre porte
donc si vous faites ça donc oui c'est
votre carcasse sur 2000 mètres de
dénivelé vous allez à la fin pas 5 fois
pardon dix fois la tour Montparnasse 6
fois la Tour Eiffel on enlève 10 fois la
tour Montparnasse et bien à la fin de la
journée vous aurez restitué grâce à vos
jambes un ridicule de 8 kWh d'énergie
mécanique
un ridicule Issime devrais-je dire
demi-kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique
tout petit nous sommes tout petits
d'accord donc si nous n'avions pas les
machines pour agir sur l'environnement
l'environnement on n'aurait pas de
problème avec
si vous faites ça un jour sur deux ou
pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent
vous faites une étape du GR20 tous les
jours voilà du 1er janvier au 31
décembre tous les jours et bien à la fin
de l'année vous aurez fourni 100 kWh
d'énergie mécanique avec vos jambes donc
si je mets quelqu'un au travail de force
pour modifier de la matière creuser des
trous s'il y a des arbres les
transporter etc planter du blé et bien
cette personne va pouvoir me fournir
dans l'année sans kilowatt-heure de
transformation de l'environnement
puisque je vous ai dit que l'énergie
c'est par définition la transformation
de l'environnement
si maintenant je prends monsieur
Schwarzenegger parce que vous allez
avoir du mal et que je lui demande enfin
que je lui demande quand il était jeune
de Me décaisser 15 tonnes de terre tous
les jours
avec les bras un peu que le dos ça va
faire mal et bien il est 10 fois plus
ridicule que mon alpiniste qui précède
puisque à la fin de la journée il aura
restitué 0,05 kWh d'énergie mécanique à
chaque fois le calcul que j'utilise pour
ceux d'entre vous à qui ça fait pas peur
c'est eux = MGH simplicité biblique
et s'il fait ça un jour sur deux parce
qu'il faut quand même qu'il se repose un
peu et bien à la fin de l'année il
m'aura fourni 10 kWh d'énergie mécanique
et bien 10 kWh d'énergie non pas
mécanique thermique c'est ce que
j'obtiens en brûlant un litre d'essence
donc je prends un litre d'essence alors
vous savez qu'en France on est tout
nucléaire
qui n'a jamais entendu qu'en France on
était tout nucléaire
alors donc j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous dans un pays où tout nucléaire on
consomme pas de pétrole évidemment sinon
on n'est pas tout nucléaire français
consomme 1000 litres de pétrole par an
en moyenne
on paye tout nucléaire c'est pas mal
donc dans un litre de pétrole qui vaut
le Prix scandaleusement cher d'un euro
quelque chose
scandale scandale absolue et bien vous
avez 10 kWh d'énergie thermique donc de
chaleur et cette chaleur vous allez la
transformer en mouvement dans un moteur
et Monsieur Carnot a dit pas de chance
vous aurez pas 10 kilowatts de mouvement
à la fin c'est interdit vous en aurez
entre deux et quatre c'est déjà pas mal
parce que ça veut dire que dans un litre
d'essence qui vaut le Prix scandaleux
d'un euro quelque chose vous avez la
même capacité à transformer
l'environnement c'est ça que ça veut
dire la même que ce que vous avez dans
10 à 100 jours de travail de force d'un
individu
donc en fait l'énergie ne vaut rien elle
est pas chère elle est pas
scandaleusement chère elle est
scandaleusement gratuite quand on
comprend et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
mis à ce goberger avec alors la raison
pour laquelle c'est scandaleusement
gratuit on y viendra un peu plus tard
c'est pas juste parce que nous sommes
des pervers polymorphes
si je compare en terme économique
ce qu'il me faut payer pour extraire un
kilowatt-heure de l'environnement un
kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique de
l'environnement si je passe par un homme
une femme je vais payer quelques
centaines à quelques milliers d'euros
par kilowattheure mécanique extrait de
l'environnement si j'utilise une
carcasse humaine en la payant au SMIC
alors que dans le même temps si
j'extrais ce kilowattheure de
l'environnement avec une machine qui
fonctionne au pétrole ou si je
transforme l'environnement à hauteur
d'un kilowattheure pour être plus précis
et bien ça va me coûter moins d'un euro
beaucoup moins d'un euro de l'ordre du
10e d'euros dit autrement quand je passe
de l'homme qui fait des trous avec ses
mains à la machine le tractopelle par
exemple qui fait des trous avec
l'énergie et bien je suis capable
d'appliquer un facteur diviseur de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
sur le coup unitaire d'une
transformation de l'environnement et
voilà pourquoi vous êtes dans cette
salle
parce que à Decoste les machines ont
travaillé pour vous pour construire vos
logements vous déplacer vous nourrir
vous chauffer vous habiller et faire le
smartphone dont vous ou vos enfants
rêves voilà Kratos tout ça quasiment
gratos quasiment gratos
à cause de notre énergie et cette
énergie dans la vision que je vous
propose est la même fait quelque chose
de très profond dans les relations
sociales elle a supprimé l'esclavage
imaginons que je prenne un esclave
alors peut-être que certains dans cette
salle ont ce genre d'occupation comme
vocation de jeunesse une option pas très
nombreux en général
puis ils le disent pas tout le monde
donc si je prends un esclave en général
c'est quelqu'un qui n'en a pas vraiment
envie on peut réserver sur ce genre
d'orientation professionnelle
ce qui veut dire que si je prends un
esclave je vais devoir payer pour aller
chercher cette personne contre sa
volonté je vais devoir payer de voir
investir des moyens pour l'empêcher de
me suicider ou [ __ ] le camp et puis je
vais devoir faire ce qu'il faut pour que
cette personne reste vivante donc la
nourrir la vêtir la loger etc donc même
si je paye pas son travail quand même
payer quelque chose et bien ce quelque
chose mi bout à bout si vous faites ce
calcul parfaitement sordide j'en
conviens mais quand même éclairant et
bien vous vous rendez compte que même un
esclave va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois
plus cher que la machine qui n'aurait
pas de vous trucider enfin pas encore
pour le moment peut-être que ça viendra
un jour
qui ne se met pas en grève c'est pareil
peut-être que le jour elle deviendra
vraiment humaine elle aura envie de se
mettre en grève c'est comme ça qu'on
verra que la machine est devenue
vraiment humaine
ou quand elle vous traitera de vieux con
et donc c'est c'est absolument pas
intéressant de prendre quelqu'un qui a
tous ses défauts toutes ces faiblesses
alors que la machine qui n'en a aucune
vous fait le même boulot pour 10 à 100
fois moins cher donc dans la vision que
je vous propose la raison pour laquelle
on a supprimé l'esclavagisme dans
l'essentiel des pays du monde c'est pas
du tout parce que vous êtes devenu bon
alors que vos ancêtres étaient
malfaisants méchants etc vous avez et
j'ai très exactement le même code
génétique que les gens qui vivaient sur
terre il y a deux siècles le même
nombre de chromosomes les mêmes
la raison pour laquelle nous on ne
recourt pas à cette forme de rapport
humain alors que eux ils recouraient
c'est parce que à l'époque ça avait un
intérêt économique que ça n'a plus haut
c'est la plus du tout aujourd'hui
alors renverser le raisonnement si on y
prend pas garde c'est évident que la
décrue énergétique non gérée ramènera de
l'attention dans les rapports sociaux et
dans l'excellent bouquin que je vous ai
conseillé de lire tout à l'heure qui est
même pas disponible avant ici je pense
que font les organisateurs et bien vous
verrez que le riz enfin je vois déjà
dans le vote dit populiste qui soit à
gauche ou à droite les prémices de ce
délitement des rapports sociaux qui
caractérisent le début d'un système qui
est sous tension au point de vue de son
approvisionnement énergétique et ce
système c'est la France en fait c'est
l'Europe
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure alors pour
le moment on va continuer l'histoire
je le redis on a aujourd'hui un tout
petit sujet avec les convicitifs
fossiles j'y reviendrai qui s'appelle
enfin double sujet qui s'appelle
l'approvisionnement et qui s'appelle le
changement climatique
il se trouve qu'il y a de siècles nous
avons déjà fait une première fois une
expérience 100% vénère on n'a pas besoin
de l'ADEM à l'époque on a vraiment fait
un monde 100% en air donc je peux vous
dire l'expérience fonctionne on l'a
faite une fois à l'époque on était 500
millions d'agriculteurs 30 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance en 25
dans les villes 30 dans les campagnes
parce qu'à l'époque il y avait pas
d'hôpitaux il y avait les miasmes dans
les villes donc il est plus jeune enfin
moi plus jeune plutôt mais donc on l'a
déjà fait une fois donc c'est absolument
certain que ça marche 100% ENR pas la
peine de se gratter la tête est-ce que
ça marche pour 7 milliards d'au moins
industrialiste ça c'est une question pas
complètement persuadé mais que ça marche
pour maintenir l'espèce en vie je n'ai
strictement aucune inquiétude à ce
propos
donc on n'avait que des ENR il y a deux
siècles et donc la bonne question c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'est emmerdé à
passer au combustible fossiles si
maintenant il faut s'en débarrasser
et c'était un peu ballot quand même
quand on y pense
alors la raison c'est la physique qui
nous la donne je vais imaginer que je
prends le volume de cette salle qui au
premier ordre représente un cube de 10
mètres de côté en fait ça doit être un
peu moins ici mais pas peu importe
j'imagine que je fais souffler ce vent à
80 km/h c'est à dire un peu plus de 49
ou un bon Mistral et que je fais passer
ce vent dans une éolienne qui va donc
récupérer une partie de l'énergie
cinétique de l'air en mouvement et bien
la quantité d'énergie que je vais
pouvoir récupérer de la sorte avec un
rendement de 40% de l'éolienne c'est la
même chose que ce que j'ai dans 3 ml de
pétrole
trois petits millilitres de pétrole
ridicule ici
à gauche les marchandises sont livrées
quand le vent souffle le train avance
quand le vent souffle enfin si le train
fonctionne à l'électricité et le
professeur qui a besoin de l'électricité
fait court quand le vent souffle alors
en fait à l'époque il y avait pas tout
ça mais par contre il y avait vraiment
la marine marchande qui vous livrez
quand le vent souffler
et puis si vous essayez de faire 30
millions de voitures en France propulsé
avec des voiles ça va vous poser un tout
petit sujet remarquer ce sera esthétique
vous allez transformer les voitures en 3
mars ça sera joli moi qui aiment bien
les bateaux je trouve ça sympa mais vous
avez quand même avoir un tout petit
sujet pour être capable de faire
fonctionner le système à droite vous
avez une densité énergétique par unité
de volume sans équivalent sans
équivalent donc vous pouvez transporter
l'énergie avec vous dans des tout petits
volumes donc vous pouvez vous
transporter partout
par ailleurs ça vous coûte très peu de
travail humain parce que on ne paye que
des hommes je le répète ça vous coûte
très peu de travail humain d'aller
chercher un kilowatt-heure dans
l'environnement littéralement il y a
qu'à se baisser pour le ramasser
il y a qu'à se baisser pour le ramasser
littéralement
et comme c'est déjà présent sous terre
de manière extrêmement concentrée parce
que Mère Nature a fait le boulot pour
nous pourquoi c'est très concentré parce
que Mère Nature a pris tout ce qui a
vécu sur Terre en fait particulièrement
des microalgues et du plancton et en
l'espace de quelques dizaines de
millions d'années on a pris une toute
petite fraction de l'ordre du millième
de milliardième la cuit avec la
géothermie sous terre donc en fait la
distillée et a fait du gaz du pétrole du
charbon qu'on a concentré ensuite dans
des roches poreuses s'appelle les
gisements de pétrole et vous avez plus
qu'à mettre un tuyau là-dedans et ça
sort
en 300 millions d'années gratuits
pour que le pétrole existe
donc le pétrole est aussi gratuit que le
vent ce qui coûte dans tous les cas de
figure c'est d'aller le chercher donc
aller chercher du vent ça vous demande
de mettre en œuvre des installations
beaucoup plus conséquentes que d'aller
chercher du pétrole par kilowattheure
exprès parce que le vent c'est beaucoup
plus diffus et beaucoup moins pilotable
que le pétrole parce qu'à droite vous
avez déjà votre fonction de stock à
droite vous consommez déjà le pétrole
quand vous avez décidé d'appuyer sur
l'accélérateur pour venir ici c'est pas
bien d'avoir pris votre voiture mais
quand même vous le faites quand vous en
avez envie
à gauche c'est quand la nature a décidé
c'est la raison pour laquelle
en sortie d'éolienne aujourd'hui alors
les progrès techniques permettront
peut-être de faire mieux mais je
rappelle que les progrès techniques
aujourd'hui sont dus à l'énergie fossile
si vous arrivez à faire vos éoliennes
plus vite et moins cher c'est parce que
vous allez utiliser plus de moyens
techniques donc de pétrole de gaz et de
Charbon Pour faire vous éoliennes
trucs
le jour où vous n'aurez plus que des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes pour
faire la métallurgie la mine la chimie
amont etc pour refaire des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes on en
reparlera du méga water solaire à 15
euros
vous oubliez fini terminé donc le
système est asservi c'est le même
problème que l'agriculture à 2% du PIB
tout à l'heure on borne le système là où
on a envie de le borner pour se raconter
une belle histoire
c'est toujours pareil cette affaire
donc aujourd'hui c'est quelques centimes
par kilowattheure ça peut baisser un peu
mon avis c'est que plus on se rencontre
sur les ressources et puis ça va monter
ça peut être l'inverse et si vous
rajoutez la sécurité d'approvisionnement
c'est-à-dire le fait que le RER en
retard dont je parlais tout à l'heure
par bien à 8h10 et pas quand il y a du
vent
sinon votre patron vous engueule je
pense qu'aujourd'hui si vous arrivez au
bureau en disant où vous arrivez à la
fac en disant je suis désolé je suis pas
venu il y avait pas de vent
la société est pas vraiment organisée
comme ça aujourd'hui
elle pourrait encore une fois elle
pourrait il y a pas d'impossibilité
physique mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fonctionne donc vous avez à ce moment la
sécurité d'approvisionnement à rajouter
c'est à dire que le RER part bien quand
vous avez décidé de partir au boulot à
ce moment vous triplez à s'exupler le
prix dont il est question parce que ce
qui coûte très cher avec des sources non
pilotables c'est de les rendre
pilotables
à droite 03 centimes par kilowattheure
imbattable alors là c'est le coût
technique d'extraction il se trouve que
comme le disait Giraud le pétrole c'est
avant tout un produit fiscal donc quand
vous payez de l'essence vous payez que
des taxes alors vous en payez à l'état
consommateur mais vous en payez aussi
plein à l'état producteur pas croire le
coût technique d'extraction d'un baril
en Arabie Saoudite reste de l'ordre de
10 dollars donc quand le baril est à 80
les 70 de différence c'est des taxes
c'est les rentes que le pays producteur
perçoit enfin moins les intermédiaires
etc mais vous avez énormément de rentes
qui partent donc de taxes qui partent à
l'état producteur
donc vous avez un rapport hors sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui est de l'ordre
de 30 et si vous rajoutez la sécurité
d'approvisionnement vous vous baladez
aux alentours de 100
la raison pour laquelle on est passé des
énergies renouvelables merveilleuses aux
énergies fossiles diaboliques elle est
là c'est que vous avez besoin de
mobiliser 100 fois moins de monde pour
sortir l'énergie de l'environnement et
donc vous êtes capable d'augmenter la
productivité de tous les autres de tous
les autres terriens grâce aux machines
et vous êtes capable d'offrir le niveau
de vie que vous avez
la civilisation dans laquelle 70% des
gens sont occupés à extraire de
l'énergie de l'environnement ça
s'appelle une civilisation agricole
donc le grand paradoxe c'est que plus
vous allez je sais pas qu'il faut pas le
faire je dis que la contrepartie de
rajouter des gens dans la filière
énergétique c'est que plus vous en avez
moins la société est productive
c'est ça le grand paradoxe donc quand
vous dites je vais créer plein d'emplois
dans la filière énergétique elle-même le
grand paradoxe c'est que plus vous en
créer moins vous avez globalement de
service
je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas le faire je
dis que ça se gère comme ça donc si on
le veut c'est comme ça que ça se gère
cette énergie elle est quand même
merveilleuse puisqu'elle nous permet de
changer l'environnement d'aller sur la
lune etc donc c'est quand même rigolo
tout ça dans des grands enfants voilà
comment a évolué la consommation par
excusez-moi j'avais dit qu'il fallait
pas que je dise consommation d'énergie
parce que vous ne mangez pas le bois non
plus donc l'utilisation d'énergie par
personne depuis un siècle et demi pour
ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent cette
courbe j'ai récemment mis la main sur
des séries historiques en ce qui
concerne la consommation de bois qui
était plus fiable que celle que
j'utilisais avant donc ça change pas mal
l'approvisionnement par personne au
début de la série par contre sur le
reste ça change rien
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que il y a
un siècle et demi l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne et surtout le
fait de bois et ce bois sert
essentiellement à produire de la chaleur
donc avec on se chauffe
on commence également à faire
fonctionner des forges à faire
fonctionner les premières machines à
vapeur
mais quand même avec ça on fait beaucoup
de chaleur est-ce que vous voyez c'est
que à part le bois qui ramenait à
l'individu a baissé en un siècle et demi
toutes les autres énergies que nous
avons commencé à mobiliser à notre
profit il y en a pas une en gros qui est
cédé la place à une autre
donc on a commencé à utiliser du charbon
l'approvisionnement en charbon par
personne s'est mis à croître rapidement
vous voyez là puis il est resté constant
pendant un siècle puis c'est remis à
croître rapidement ici donc il n'a
jamais décru depuis qu'on utilise du
charbon en tendance depuis un siècle et
demi jamais la quantité de charbon
utilisée par personne n'a été aussi
élevé qu'aujourd'hui et je peux vous
dire que c'est vrai également en France
puisque à chaque fois que vous achetez
un produit qui a été made in China il a
été made in charbon
donc la consommation de charbon de la
Chine qui est responsable de cet effet
de moyenne ici sur les 15 dernières
années vous le retrouvez vous la
retrouver plus exactement dans
l'augmentation des exportations
chinoises et donc dès que vous avez un
truc made in China encore une fois vous
avez utilisé que vous achetez vous avez
utilisé du charbon
aujourd'hui le charbon ne décroît pas
pour une raison assez simple et on le
verra tout à l'heure c'est que les deux
tiers du charbon utilisé sur terre
servent à alimenter les centrales
électriques alors là aussi vous
peut-être pas dans cette salle mais
l'essentiel des gens à qui on dit
électricité dans le monde il pense
nucléaire il pense éventuellement et Oli
or il se trouve que dans le monde la
première et de loin source de production
électrique fait appel au charbon
et comme l'électricité c'est l'énergie
finale qui a cru le plus vite sur les
dernières décennies et bien la
consommation de charbon n'a jamais
baissé par personne et encore moins en
valeur absolue
au charbon on a rajouté le pétrole
pétrole n'a pas du tout supprimer le
charbon il lui sera ajouté par dessus
alors pourquoi parce que le pétrole ne
sert pas du tout la même chose que le
charbon le pétrole à cause de son
extraordinaire densité énergétique par
unité de volume par unité de poids plus
exactement et bien il sert à au
transport avant tout l'essentiel de ce
qui se déplace sur terre utilisent du
pétrole 100% des avions malgré celui de
Monsieur Picard et malgré l'avion à
hydrogène s'appelle la fusée Ariane mais
sinon pas beaucoup
100% de ce qui navigue quelques
cerfs-volants ici et là mais globalement
c'est du pétrole
et 90% de ce qui roule en gros utilise
du pétrole donc tout ça mi bout à bout
fait que 98% de l'énergie qu'on utilise
pour se déplacer c'est du pétrole
et puis là dessus vous avez eu du gaz
qui s'est rajouté de l'hydroélectricité
du nucléaire et alors notre grande
aventure des cinq dernières années la
voici
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
alors je vais faire une première petite
insiste sur les médias que j'adore
beaucoup les médias le problème des
médias qui c'est qui s'affronter jusqu'à
donc une catastrophe c'est une fille qui
se fait violer c'est une ville qui
disparaît dans un tremblement de terre
c'est un tsunami qui fait 200000 morts
où c'est éventuellement 10% de baisse à
la Bourse de Paris voilà tout ça c'est
une catastrophe donc ils s'affronter
jusqu'à 1 et le problème des gens et
donc c'est un communiqué de presse par
panneau solaire qu'on installe un
communiqué de presse pareil éolienne
qu'on installe un communiqué de presse
par je sais pas quoi donc à chaque fois
c'est un
tout ça mes bout à bout crée un effet de
masse qui fait que le lecteur du journal
qui ne fait pas gaffe et j'ai été comme
vous enfin en tout cas comme ceux
d'entre vous qui ne font pas gaffe très
longtemps et très très longtemps à
comprendre comment ça marchait
à l'impression que la masse dans le
journal fait l'importance dans le monde
il n'y a aucun rapport entre les deux
zéro aucun aucun il n'y a pas le moindre
rapport entre l'importance paginale
pagination dans un média et l'importance
réelle d'un processus dans le monde il y
a aucun lien il y a un vrai lien entre
la quantité de communiquer de presse
c'est pour ça que ma société en fait de
temps en temps sinon ça servait à rien
donc il y a un rapport entre la quantité
de communiquer de presse et la
pagination dans le journal ça c'est
absolument certain il y a strictement
aucun rapport entre l'importance réelle
des processus dans le monde et la
pagination dans le journal c'est
perturbant de vous dire ça veut dire
vous pouvez pas avoir confiance en
n'importe quel chiffre que vous lisez
dans le journal tant que vous ne
connaissez pas le journaliste qui
travaille sur la question une fois que
vous le connaissez vous savez comment il
bosse là vous savez à qui vous pouvez
faire confiance
alors ce que vous voyez là c'est ramener
à l'individu l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondiale agrégé de l'éolien
du photovoltaïque duolomoteur du Marais
moteur du biogaz de la géothermie
qu'est-ce que j'oublie de l'énergie des
vagues enfin bref tout quoi
sauf les deux grandes énergies
renouvelables qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
dans le monde c'est-à-dire le bois et
l'hydroélectricité donc c'est tout le
reste
alors faisons vite l'accord de Paris en
maintenant votre confort de vie
c'est-à-dire au premier ordre votre
quantité d'énergie utilisée par personne
c'est-à-dire au premier ordre la
quantité de machine que vous utilisez
chaque jour
ça revient à ce que le petit machin
violet là supprime tout le reste en 35
ans
c'est ça l'accord de Paris
donc vous avez la réponse est-ce qu'on
va respecter l'accord de Paris on rentre
chez dames j'ai encore une demi-heure à
causer donc
ça va pas être comme ça ça va pas être
comme ça et là vous commencez à toucher
du doigt le problème c'est que le
problème c'est que l'essentiel de ce qui
fait votre niveau de vie c'est le
carbone
l'essentiel
donc je vais vous le dire d'une autre
manière les deux degrés c'est organisé
une récession massive
peut-être qu'il faut le faire mais c'est
bien de ça dont on parle
c'est bien de ça dont on parle
alors la deuxième partie de l'exposé
c'est que même si on veut pas je pense
qu'on aura quand même mais
et le premier qui nous a dit ça je vous
fais l'économie aujourd'hui des
citations c'est Marcel Boiteux pour ceux
d'entre vous que ça intéresse Marcel
Boiteux brillante économiste et ancien
président DDF a publié en 2006 si ma
mémoire est bonne un papier qui
s'appelle éloge des écotaxes aller lire
ce papier c'est brillantissime ça fait
partie de ces papiers où il y a pas un
mot qui est écrit au hasard il y a pas
une phrase qui est pas à sa place c'est
un condensé d'intelligence et lisez la
fin je pense que ça va un peu vous
secouer
alors il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui
si je regarde l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne et bien j'ai de
l'ordre de 20000 kilowattheure par
personne et par an alors c'est
kilowattheure je le redis vont dans des
machines la machine tatati tatata un
homme c'est 100 kWh d'énergie mécanique
donc je fais une règle de trois
grossières et ma règle de trois
grossières me dit que le niveau de vie
du terrien moyen aujourd'hui à cause de
l'énergie c'est-à-dire des machines et
le même que si il avait 200 esclaves à
sa disposition H24
le même et en France on est plutôt à
cinq ou six ans
donc la vérité indicible derrière ce
graphique c'est que le niveau de vie du
smicard français n'est pas durable
elle est là la vérité indicible
et ça va pas durer et ça a déjà commencé
à ne pas durer et il s'en rend compte et
il vote avec ses pieds il reste mais
elle est bien là il est bien là le
problème
deuxième problème c'est quand on dit bah
il y a pas enfin voilà non pardon
alors on utilise pas juste de plus en
plus de machines par personne on est
aussi un tout petit peu plus nombreux
vous aurez remarqué
l'autre jour j'ai été invité avec un
démographe à une émission sur la
question de la population mondiale et
l'animateur a posé à brûle pourpoint aux
trois qui étaient autour de la table on
avait chacun je crois entre 10 et 20 ans
d'écart
quelle était la taille de la population
mondiale qu'on vous apprenez à l'école
primaire
alors les plus jeunes dans cette salle
on leur a 17 milliards à mon époque
c'était plus de 3 et à l'époque de mes
parents c'est plutôt
deux quand même monter très vite donc si
vous faites approvisionnement par
personne fois non d'individus voilà ce
que ça vous donne
alors à partir de ce graphique vous
pouvez faire quelques petites analyses
et j'ai regardé par exemple quel était
l'énergie ici qui avait le plus augmenté
sur les 15 dernières années
donc on sait qu'on est truffé de
combustible fossiles et on se dit bon on
va peut-être que depuis le temps qu'on
nous dit c'est pas bon pour la santé on
va se mettre à faire autre chose donc je
regarde quel est l'énergie qui augmente
le plus sur les 15 dernières années
parce que vous savez bien que on
installe les éoliennes partout
voilà la réponse
la première marche du podium revient à
King coal
c'est le charbon qui a plus augmenter
sur les 15 dernières années enfin les 16
juste derrière on va trouver une
deuxième énergie fossile le gaz juste
derrière une troisième énergie fossile
ce que j'ai appelé oil ici en fait c'est
les liquides mais peu importe
c'est les carburants
la première énergie renouvelable vient
loin derrière et soit dit en passant
c'est de l'hydroélectricité et la grande
hydraulique
on peut débattre sur ces très grandes
vertus environnementales en fait comme
l'énergie c'est par définition
transformer ce qui nous entoure le drame
c'est que dès que vous transformez
beaucoup vous avez beaucoup de
sous-produit et beaucoup d'effets
indésirables donc toute énergie devient
sale dès lors qu'elle devient
massivement utilisée il y en a pas une
qui fait exception parce que par
définition utilisez plein d'énergie
c'est beaucoup perturbé l'environnement
par définition c'est à ça que ça sert ça
sert à changer ce qui nous entoure et
donc changer ce qui nous entoure ça ne
peut pas être laissé les toilettes dans
l'état dans lequel on les a trouvé en
entrant ça sert justement à l'inverse
et vous voyez que les queues de cerises
dont on vous parle souvent là le vent le
salaire etc c'est enfin c'est des queues
de cerise quoi
si je fais un tout petit ratio sur les
15 dernières années j'aurais dû trouver
20 fois plus de papier sur le charbon
dans le journal que je n'ai trouvé de
papier sur les sur le soleil
et un petit 10 fois plus sur le charbon
que sur l'éolien vous pourrez constater
que c'est pas vraiment la même chose
vous allez dire oui mais sur les années
récentes et puis juste sur l'électricité
etc alors très bien on peut faire la
même chose j'ai regardé la variation de
la production électrique dans le monde
sur les six dernières années alors six
dernières années ça commence à pas être
très très long hein d'accord avec moi et
j'ai regardé ce qu'il y avait plus
augmenté bah c'est la production
électrique au combustible fossiles qui a
le plus augmenté
voilà donc pour le moment on n'est pas
du tout du tout du tout en train de se
décarboner
pour le moment on est en train de
continuer à ramasser tout ce qu'on
trouve et vous avez ici un graphique sur
la production électrique mondiale qui
vous donne la décomposition de cette
production électrique par grand type
d'énergie primaire utilisée alors oui
les énergéticiens ils utilisent ils ont
un jargon et si vous voyez l'adjectif
primaire ça veut dire c'est celle qui
sort de l'environnement je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure la loi de conservation de
l'énergie nous interdit de faire autre
chose que de commencer par prendre une
énergie dans l'environnement puis après
on la tripatouille on en fait autre
chose l'énergie qu'on sort de
l'environnement s'appelle une énergie
primaire alors là dedans vous allez
trouver des trucs qui brûlent de l'eau
qui tombe des chutes d'eau le
rayonnement solaire qui vous arrive
dessus le bois qui a poussé tout seul
etc ça c'est de l'énergie primaire après
les carburants pétroliers que vous allez
faire à partir du pétrole ça vous
trouvez pas tout prêt dans la nature
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
énergie finale c'est celle qui a la
qualité suffisante pour être mise dans
une machine
c'est final parce que ça sort du système
énergétique
l'électricité tant qu'on branchera pas
les cafetières sur les éclairs d'orage
est une énergie finale
l'hydrogène dont la presse a commencé à
parler ces derniers jours est une
énergie finale il n'existe pas de
réservoir d'hydrogène sur Terre dans
l'univers il y en a plein vous en avez
plein dans les étoiles mais c'est un peu
compliqué d'accès donc le tuyau de 150
km de long
même rêve Ventura il y avait pas pensé
donc parce qu'il y a une chanson sur les
tuyaux
et donc le l'énergie qu'on met dans les
machines donc c'est une énergie finale
et l'hydrogène fait partie des énergies
finales donc passer à l'hydrogène ça
vous résout pas du tout votre problème
tant que vous n'avez pas changé
d'énergie primaire
on sait très bien faire de l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui en craquant du méthane ça
vous fait du CO2 en tant que vous voulez
donc le c'est pas parce que sur place il
y a rien
que ça n'aimait pas
alors avec quoi fait-on de l'électricité
aujourd'hui pour 40 % avec du charbon là
il y a une équivalence un pour un que
vous pouvez garder en mémoire un
kilowatt-heure au charbon un kilo de CO2
ça c'est simple un peu moins des fois
quand c'est très efficace avec du gaz
deux fois moins pas mal encore avec du
pétrole vous voyez que soit dit en
passant la quantité en valeur absolue de
kilowattheure qui sort des centrales au
fioul c'est presque la même chose qu'il
y a 30 ans par relative ça a baissé
après la première grande électricité bas
carbone dans le monde c'est
l'hydroélectricité la deuxième c'est le
nucléaire et après vous allez trouver
les trucs qui sont là-haut alors le
solaire c'est le truc orange là si vous
avez
mis vos bas de lunettes ou que vous avez
une bonne vue si vous avez vu de l'aigle
vous pouvez le voir et le grand paradoxe
c'est que ces énergies sont pas du tout
des carbonées nécessairement enfin pas
de tout très décarbonée parce qu'il faut
fabriquer le panneau il faut fabriquer
l'éolienne et si en plus vous stockez il
faut fabriquer la batterie alors ordre
de grandeur l'éolien c'est 10 à 20 g de
CO2 par kilowattheure non stockés
stockés sur batterie c'est de l'ordre de
100 à 200 g de CO2 par kilowattheure
stocké restitué donc c'est pas du tout
négligeable le panneau solaire ça se
balade entre 50 et 100 si vous mettez
aussi les armatures les clôtures les
machins etc
cette énergie nous a donc permis de
mobiliser des convertisseurs qui sont
beaucoup plus puissants que nous alors
avec le petit parallèle que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure là de mon de mon bonhomme
qui est arrivé à faire 10 à 100
kilowattheure par an ça veut dire qu'en
terme de puissance donc l'énergie
divisée par le temps la puissance
moyenne de vos bras c'est 10 watts c'est
la plus terrible regardez 10 watts et la
puissance moyenne de vos jambes c'est
100 watts alors vous prenez le champion
du monde de cycliste sur piste lui fait
700 watts pendant une minute et demi
après il est pas beau à voir et il a des
cuisses qui sont grosses comme ma
poitrine ou à peu près chacune
évidemment
lui 700 watts
prenez un tracteur le premier tracteur
venu quelques dizaines de kilowatts ça
vous remplace quelques centaines de
paires de jambes ou quelques dizaines
d'animaux de traits raison pour laquelle
dès que vous augmentez
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans un
pays vous voyez la fraction de la
population active qui bosse dans
l'agriculture qui baisse
c'est mécanique ça se passe comme ça
partout
un engin de travaux publics permet de
faire votre logement en 6 mois alors que
Notre-Dame il a fallu un siècle et une
tour à la défense en un an alors que
Notre Dame il a fallu un siècle
ce sont donc des esclaves des temps
modernes qui ont permis d'abaisser très
fortement le coût du logement je peux
vous dire que les 500000 logements dont
rêvéoland déjà avec ça il a du mal sans
ça vous oubliez
sans ça si vous en faites 3000 par an
c'est bon
à l'époque on avait pas ça quand la
demeure familiale s'agrandissait d'une
pièce au cours d'une vie c'était déjà
bon
le camion [ __ ] comme quelques milliers
de fois les jambes du conducteur et
l'avion comme un million de fois les
gens du pilote c'est pour ça que le
pilote est mieux payé
et enfin un laminoir Martel comme toute
l'Île de France à qui j'aurais donné un
marteau pour taper sur des tôles
des millions de paires de bras et ça
c'est piloté par une personne il faut
que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de visiter à
laminoir vous avez une personne dans la
cabine de pilotage un instant donné
alors c'est en 38 ça fait trois
personnes
donc c'est Superman pour de vrai je le
redis vous prenez une personne qui fait
100 watts et vous la mettez à la tête
dans la baignoire un million de fois
plus puissant c'est super mal pour de
vrai alors évidemment ça va pas la forme
du Superman que vous voyez dans les
films là qui vole etc qui courent
derrière Supergirl
mais par contre c'est vraiment un exové
surpuissant encore une fois c'est pas
très sexy ça vous fait même pas peur
comme Terminator mais c'est un
exosquelette c'est très exactement ça
c'est un exosquelette surpuissant
le problème dans cette histoire il
arrive avec lui
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter
jusqu'à maintenant aurait été un non
sujet absolu de conférence si l'unité de
compte qu'on s'était choisi pour mesurer
la transformation du monde physique
avait été l'énergie
pas besoin vous emmerdez à venir ici ce
soir
ça serait juste pas un sujet on
compresse qui compte vraiment et puis
voilà ça malheureusement il y a un homme
qui est passé par là c'est pas le seul
il y a toute une bande d'économistes qui
sont passés par là il y a deux siècles
et qui se sont dit voyons voir
l'économie c'est la gestion de la
ressourcera qu'est-ce qui est rare il y
a deux siècles pas les ressources
naturelles nous sommes 500 millions
d'agriculteurs sur une terre immense
donc les ressources naturelles je m'en
fous au premier ordre je considère que
le stock est illimité
ce qu'il a dit et du coup si le stock
est illimité Delta stock vaut 0 donc je
m'emmerde pas comme le savant cosinus à
balader les plus zéro partout dans mes
équations
j'oublie
et du coup on a transformé la physique
en une convention l'économie qu'on
utilise partout autour de nous qui ne
s'intéresse pas par construction à la
physique mais à la seule chose qui était
le facteur limitant de la transformation
du monde physique à l'époque
c'est-à-dire les hommes
et voici comment au lieu de représenter
correctement l'économie avec un système
de flux physique on la représenté avec
un système conventionnel économique donc
dont vous avez deux input c'est ce que
vous avez appris à l'école est-ce que la
personne la plus jeune dans cette salle
peut me confirmer que c'est encore comme
ça qu'on apprend l'économie
je crois
donc vous avez deux facteurs de
production c'est pas comme ça qu'on
apprend l'économie des deux facteurs de
production le capital et le travail on
est d'accord
et vous avez du capital et du travail et
hop je me supermarché se remplit
Magic économique je donne un coup de
baguette magique sur le supermarché et
il se remplit
alors il se trouve qu'à la même époque
il y avait un polytechnicien
Charles Dupin
Monsieur Charles Dupin x 1801 voilà
Monsieur Charles Dupin à l'époque lui
donc moi j'ai rien inventé avec les
esclaves énergétiques et tous ceux qui
ont parlé d'esclaves énergétique avant
moi jusqu'à monsieur Dupin rien inventé
non plus d'accord ça fait deux siècles
que le concept existe juste il est passé
sous le tapis pendant le siècle ou
clinique
monsieur Dupin dit quoi il dit en France
nous avons certes des gens capables de
travailler avec leur bras et l'argent
jambes donc une population active du
reste on se demande si c'est pas de
cette époque que date l'expression ma
moitié pour ma femme parce que cette
espèce de règle sexiste avait compté la
force productive des hommes pour 1 et
celle des femmes pour un demi voilà ça
reste entre eux
mais donc monsieur Dupin il dit certes
nous avons des hommes et des femmes ou
dans l'autre sens peu importe
mais nous avons également des machines
alors à l'époque les machines c'est des
moulins vous voyez avant hydrauliques
etc des machines à vapeur et il dit si
je transforme ça en équivalent carcasse
en équivalent esclave en équivalent
homme au travail et bien vous voyez que
je rajoute à la population française 5
millions d'hommes virtuels et à la
population grande bretonne 20 millions
d'hommes virtuel voilà et donc il dit si
je rajoute ça aux gens qui vivent
vraiment plus les animaux etc et bien la
France produit comme si elle était
peuplée de 11 millions d'hommes valent 1
qui sont en train de travailler et la
Grande-Bretagne a la même époque soit
dit en passant produit comme si elle
avait 27 millions d'hommes va loin voilà
pourquoi la Grande-Bretagne à l'époque
est déjà une puissance industrielle de
rang supérieur à la France
et Monsieur Dupin il a tout compris il a
compris que c'est la physique qui compte
voilà donc monsieur Dupin si il avait
consulté le système économique mondial
il aurait pas du tout raisonné la même
manière il aura dit certes en sortie
j'ai une production sauf que pour
produire j'ai besoin des ressources à
transformer donc monsieur Dupin n'aurait
pas oublié que pour faire des meubles en
bois il faut du bois
c'est pas juste des investissements dans
les séries
et Monsieur Dupin il aurait également
dit il me faut cette capacité à
transformer les ressources que j'appelle
le travail
il faut absolument donc à gauche en gros
j'ai besoin du tableau de Mendeleïev
c'est-à-dire les 92 atomes qu'on trouve
sur Terre dans toute leur combinatoire
possible que je prends que je transforme
un peu je transforme les compositions
chimiques je transforme les formes etc
et j'en fais les fauteuils sur lesquels
vous êtes confortablement assis enfin
j'espère sinon il y en a plus pour
longtemps et j'ai également besoin d'une
capacité de transformation de ces
éléments
des ressources et une capacité de
transformation et alors si je reproduis
le système aujourd'hui je dis la
capacité de transformation avec le même
système de comptabilisation que celui du
Baron Du Pain et bien à la force
productive des hommes vaut 1 là je vous
avoue que je n'ai pas fait le distinguo
entre les hommes et les femmes parce que
maintenant nous vivions dans un monde
moderne et les machines utilisant leur
nourriture particulière qui s'appelle
l'énergie Val 200
ceux qui veut dire que ce qui transforme
au premier ordre le monde qui nous
entoure c'est pas vous c'est les
machines vous vous ne servez à rien
d'autre qu'à piloter des machines
moi aussi moi je pilote une machine qui
est là
et puis je pilote indirectement
exactement j'exploite je suis tributaire
on va dire d'une autre machine qui
s'appelle le RER encore tributaire d'une
autre machine qui s'appelle la chaudière
du bureau parce que sinon par les temps
qui courent venir bosser dans 5 degrés
compliqués je suis etc voilà je suis
primaire de toutes ces machines et du
téléphone s'il marche pas j'ai quelques
problèmes en fin d'Internet etc
tributeur de plein de machines
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec un
tel différentiel d'efficacité entre
l'homme et la machine vous n'avez besoin
de travail que pour piloter les machines
au travail et si l'approvisionnement
énergétique baisse ça vous explique ce
paradoxe qui est que si
l'approvisionnement énergétique se met à
baisser de manière subie il y a moins de
machines qui peuvent bosser et du coup
vous avez besoin de moins de monde
la première pensée qui viendrait à
l'esprit moins inclus pendant longtemps
c'était de dire si je baisse
l'approvisionnement énergétique il y a
moins de machines au boulot donc ça
libère de l'espace pour les hommes mais
non dans un univers de prix de marché ça
marche pas parce que le prix des prix de
la production des machines résiduelles
celles qui sont toujours capables de
bosser reste tellement bas que ça ne
rend toujours pas l'homme compétitif
pour occuper l'espace donc tout ce que
vous faites quand l'approvisionnement
énergétique baisse dans un monde de
machines avec un tel écart de
productivité entre l'homme et la machine
c'est vous créer du chômage
de la vient le chômage qui a commencé à
faire son apparition au moment des chocs
pétroliers en 74 et vous verrez dans pas
longtemps que les chocs pétroliers ça a
été une rupture de pente sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne dans le monde
donc c'est de là que ça vient donc
aujourd'hui avec un tel différentiel de
productivité moins d'énergie moins de
machines au boulot moins d'emploi aussi
simple que ça
les choix dit en passant sans vouloir
lutter contre ma Corporation qui invente
des intelligences artificielles
merveilleuses la robotisation atlarde
aura exactement cet effet
elle va encore augmenter la productivité
des machines restant au travail et donc
elle va rendre l'homme encore moins
l'augmentation de la robotisation et de
l'intelligence artificielle dans un
univers contraint sur l'énergie
vous détruit de l'emploi
c'est une affaire de dynamique
respective
alors dans cette affaire là Monsieur
Dupin aurait dit ben le système de
transformation il est limité par le
premier de ces facteurs limitants alors
le premier de ces facteurs limitant on
peut effectivement être les gens au
travail parce que c'est les pilotes
c'est l'intelligence de la machine puis
de temps en temps ils sont aussi
productifs que la machine pour recrute
des boutons par exemple pour le moment
la machine elle a du mal à faire ça vous
avez perdu votre bouton
mais par contre le facteur limitant peut
être ailleurs donc il peut être par
exemple dans les ressources si vous
n'avez pas assez de carrière localement
pour extraire du sable pour construire
des immeubles et bien vous construisez
moins d'immeubles vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement ce que je suis en train
de vous dire existe déjà dans certaines
régions du monde
mais vous pouvez également avoir un
goulet d'étranglement sur l'énergie
je zappe sur l'énergie c'est à dire la
nourriture des machines c'est juste pour
dire que le capital est produit comme le
reste un cet immeuble c'est des
ressources naturelles transformées pas
différentes
à ce moment si vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'énergie et bien
vous avez moins de machines au travail
et donc moins de PIB nonobstant le fait
que vous bottiez les fesses des chômeurs
pour qu'ils aillent bosser et nonobstant
le fait que vous bottiez les fesses des
banquiers pour que ils investissent à où
il faut
si vous avez moins d'énergie vous aurez
moins de PIB
dans notre monde de machines
si vous avez moins de ressources exemple
moins de poissons à pêcher dans la mer
vous aurez moins de produits de la pêche
c'est pareil donc vous pouvez avoir le
facteur limitant ailleurs que dans le
nombre de gens qui bossent et
sauf que à cause de monsieur sait on
s'est limite de ses petits copains c'est
juste de ces facteurs limitants dont on
s'occupe qui aujourd'hui ont cessait de
l'être il y a trop de gens capables de
bosser il y a du chômage partout
l'offre d'emploi est sûr numéraire et il
y a des bulles spéculatives partout et
trop d'argent en circulation les
capitaux on sait plus quoi en faire donc
en fait il se trouve qu'on vit
aujourd'hui un processus que je dois au
coeur d'un excellent livre qui est là et
mon actuel associé un processus
d'inversion des pénuries c'est-à-dire
que on continue de compter
ceux qui ne compte plus et on ne compte
pas ce qui s'est mis à compter vraiment
donc notre système économique est
totalement myope
voilà donc avec le schéma que je viens
de vous montrer
vous avez éventuellement l'énergie qui
peut être un facteur limitant alors tant
que vous avez plein d'énergie PIB
augmente vous avez ici un nuage de
points nuage de points ici sauf que ça
décrit une droite et c'est le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique que je connais ça
ce dernier à droite c'est le seul qui
est prédictif c'est à dire que le jour
où je suis tombé sur ce truc là
j'ai dit bah voilà quand
l'approvisionnement énergétique augmente
le PIB augmente et depuis 6 7 8 ans que
je suis ce truc là ça marche extrêmement
bien l'approvisionnement mondial
augmente PIB augmente parce que plus
d'énergie plus de machines au travail et
comme chaque machine au travail
transforme et que dans les entreprises
cette transformation s'appelle de la
valeur ajoutée et que l'empilement des
valeurs ajoutées c'est le PIB ça vous
augmente le PIB
alors ça marche on va leur absolue donc
entendez-moi bien ça ça n'est pas la
preuve que l'énergie dépend du PIB c'est
la forme normale que doit avoir la
courbe parce que avec le rapport de 1 à
200 la transformation dépend au premier
ordre des machines
donc c'est une c'est une conséquence
attendue c'est normal c'est une c'est
une preuve on va dire au sens de quelque
chose qui est logiquement attendu mais
ce n'est pas l'observation simple de ce
truc là qui vous démontre
qu'il y a un lien de cause à effet
une autre observation qui devient très
logique avec ce que je viens de vous
raconte c'est que ce que je viens de
vous raconter pardon c'est que vous
voyez que l'énergie et le PIB covarie
sur terre alors que bien évidemment la
force de travail année après année ne
varie pas de manière aussi irrégulière
les gens capables de travailler sur
terre ça zigzagouille pas comme ça en
terme d'augmentation annuelle beaucoup
plus stable ça suit la démocratie là la
démographie pardon là vous voyez bien
que la quantité de machines au travail
c'est à dire l'énergie zigzago est
fortement d'une année sur l'autre et
donc le PIB c'est à dire le produit de
ces machines zigzago est fortement d'une
année sur l'autre
dernière courbe qui devient logique avec
ce que je vous raconte vous avez ici la
production économique reconstituée
depuis la naissance de Monsieur
Jésus-Christ et ce que vous voyez c'est
que pendant très très longtemps on
n'avait pas de machine à notre
disposition donc la production mondiale
augmentait aussi vite que les hommes au
travail et les hommes au travail ça
augmentait pas vite
donc essentiellement le PIB donc montez
pas soit dit en passant alors la blague
elle est inopérante parce que dans un
monde sans croissance vous avez pas de
démocratie
la démocratie est en exercice de la
liberté individuelle dans un monde
contraint je peux pas vous laisser plus
de liberté sans en enlever à quelqu'un
d'autre
et la démocratie athénienne ou romaine
c'était juste une poignée de citoyens
libres assis sur une armée d'esclave
donc l'histoire a retenu les gens là qui
parlaient de la pluie et du beau temps
dans l'agora ils ont juste oublié que
ces gens-là étaient assis sur une arme
et d'esclave qui possèdent leur place
donc aujourd'hui on a reproduit le
système sauf que les esclaves sont innés
donc tant qu'on les a ça marche bien une
fois qu'on les aura plus
ça se met un peu
voilà donc je vous continue l'histoire
il y a quand même pas grand chose et
puis arrive messieurs what's papa et
qu'on sort et alors là craque on est
parti pour 3% par an et alors quand vous
écoutez l'économiste Bontin qui vous
explique que si l'économie ne croit plus
c'est pas ce que on fait pas ce qu'il
faut sur les charges les salaires etc
les feignants les jeunes les vieux et
les unis jambes
ouais enfin peut-être moi je pense que
sans les machines on serait là à
population donnée à la même population
et surtout en fait on serait pas là il y
aura pas de quoi nourrir les gens
la productivité agricole en France a été
multipliée par un facteur 8 depuis la
dernière guerre 1945 deux éléments
majeurs pour ça qu'ils viennent tous les
deux de l'énergie les engrais et les
tracteurs
d'accord par 8
c'est beaucoup 8
même si je vous rends tous végétariens
c'est pas sûr que on garde 65 millions
de Français si je fais une division par
avec des mauvais rendements de temps en
temps etc
voilà alors ce truc là c'est génial pour
le moment c'est génial l'objectif vous
vivez tous comme des nababs vous vivez
tous mieux qu'un noble du Moyen-Âge
oui il est mieux vous avez moins de
pouvoir ce qui est en démocratie vous
êtes insupportable tant quelqu'un a plus
que vous trouvez que c'est pas normal
vous savez il y a un très bon moyen de
résoudre les inégalités quel que soit la
personne qui parle c'est moi je suis là
résoudre les inégalités c'est j'accepte
que tous les gens qui sont là viennent
là on voit pas là
ça c'est ma manière de résoudre les
inégalités mais l'idée qu'on va résoudre
les inégalités avec moi qui fait ça non
mais attendez ça va pas la tête
c'est ça démocratie Tocqueville l'avait
très bien expliqué il y a un cycle
ennemi donc pour le moment il y a juste
pas de sujets on vit dans le monde
infini il y a plus pour tout le monde
alors le problème c'est que tout ce sur
quoi on a basé ce qu'on appelle le
développement c'est les combustibles
fossiles je les dis tout à l'heure les
combustibles fossiles il faut 50 à 300
millions d'années pour les former donc
on peut considérer qu'aux échelles de
temps qui nous intéressent
2000 ans 500 ans 100 ans pour combien de
temps ça va durer encore peu importe on
peut considérer que le stock de départ
est donné une fois pour toutes d'accord
donc sous la terre il y a une quantité
donnée de combustible fossiles et le
stock ne sera pas réévalué en cours de
partie on peut considérer que ce stock
on ne connaît pas exactement encore sur
le bout des doigts etc mais la seule
chose qui est certaine à cause du
processus de formation c'est qu'il
augmentera pas en cours de partie
quand vous tapez dans un stock de départ
qui est donné une fois pour toutes et
que vous ne pourrez plus jamais
réalimenter les mathématiques
bouddhistes que vous n'avez pas le droit
d'avoir en provenance de ce stock
une consommation indéfiniment croissante
c'est interdit sinon le stock se réinit
vous n'avez même pas le droit d'avoir
une consommation indéfiniment constante
même ça les mathématiques ou
l'interdisent
en fait les mathématiques vous disent
que en pareil cas vous n'avez qu'une
seule forme globale de courbe qui est
autorisée c'est que si vous remontez
suffisamment loin dans le temps la
consommation est nulle si vous allez
consommation sort de nouveau nulle et
quelque part entre les deux elle passera
par un maximum absolu
que dans le jargon des gens qui
s'intéressent au pétrole et par
extension aux ressources naturelles non
renouvelables on a coutume d'appeler le
pic
alors le pic s'applique ou s'appliquera
au pétrole au gaz au charbon mais il
s'applique aussi où s'appliquera alors à
l'étain au tungstène au chrome au
vanadium offert à la boxe et à la patate
tout pique pour tout le monde pas de
jaloux
dès lors que vous avez une ressource de
départ non renouvelable vous aurez un
maximum absolu à l'extraction de cette
ressource
c'est pas de l'idéologie c'est un
théorème nomade l'idéologie c'est
justement de dire que les maths sont pas
valables ça me rappelle pour ceux
d'entre vous qui la connaissent cette
blague des indigivrables je sais pas si
vous voyez les indésirables les petits
pingouins là qui se causent et il y a
une des planches que j'adore sur
lesquelles un des pingouins di à l'autre
les faits sont violemment démanties par
mon opinion donc les gens qui disent le
pic ça n'existe pas c'est exactement ce
qu'ils font
on peut dire il est tellement loin et
tellement haut que c'est pas un sujet
parce qu'on aura d'autres limites avant
ça ok on peut en débattre mais de dire
il n'existe pas ça c'est faux
alors bonne nouvelle pour nous autres
européens nous on a déjà fait la
démonstration qui existe vous avez ici
l'approvisionnement alors vu que
maintenant j'ai presque épuisé mon temps
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne en Europe et ce que vous voyez
c'est qu'on est passé par le maximum de
cette approvisionnement en fait il y a
deux temps jusqu'au choc pétrolier ça
augmente très vite à partir des chocs
pétroliers ça n'augmente plus jusqu'en
2006 et en 2006 c'est à dire deux ans
avant les vins Brothers ça commence à
décroître
regardez maintenant la variation du PIB
par personne en Europe avant les chocs
pétroliers ça augmente très vite puisque
plus d'énergie par personne c'est plus
de machines plus de transformation plus
d'économies plus de revenus
entre les chocs pétroliers de 79 et
celui de 2005 ce qu'on appelait 30
piteuses dans le jargon de certains
économistes et bien l'énergie par
personne et de votre mustable donc c'est
juste le delta d'efficacité énergétique
plus des mecs ont rien à voir avec
l'efficacité énergétique et notamment
l'endettement qui permettent de
maintenir la hausse du PIB à quelque
chose de positif et puis depuis les
chocs pétroliers de 2006
pendant cette affaire en 2005 on dit au
pays de l'Est en Europe venait donc dans
la danse vous allez refaire le coup des
Européens et des Espagnols et des
Portugais d'accord les Portugais sont
venus dans l'Europe et puis on leur a
dit grâce au marché vous allez devenir
riche parce qu'on leur a dit grâce au
marché vous allez devenir riche elles
sont pas devenus riches à son marché ils
sont devenus riches parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait encore de l'énergie et donc
je pouvais faire la résolution des
l'abolition des inégalités en faisant ça
pas de problème
après 2005 il y a plus d'énergie donc
arrive les Hongrois les Roumains etc
j'ai rien contre les Roumains je les
ancêtres humains arrivent les rois les
Roumains etc dans la danse je leur dis
venez dans le grand marché vous allez
vous enrichir alors oui on s'enrichit
sauf que si le jeu devient sombre nul
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas plus
globalement si la part du gâteau pour
les uns augmente par du gâteau pour les
autres baisses donc à ce moment vous
créez dans une Europe de libre
circulation économique une différence de
potentiel massive entre l'Est et l'Ouest
et à ce moment le système s'équilibre on
est comme ça
et du coup alors de manière les
industriels de l'Ouest investissent à
l'est et les plombiers de l'Est vont à
Londres et à ce moment on demande aux
Britanniques s'ils sont d'accord et ils
disent non on trouve pas ça drôle
c'est exactement le même phénomène qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis avec Trump
s'est passé en France avec Mélenchon et
le Pen tout ça c'est même pareil c'est
les mêmes couches sociales victimes des
mêmes processus structurels liés au fait
que nous avons fini la fête en Europe
sur la route de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne qui se
révoltent notamment à cause c'est pas ça
n'arrange pas le problème des promesses
d'Alice au pays des merveilles qui leur
sont faites par des gens qui soient
n'ont pas compris ça soit l'ont compris
en fait non je vous rassure non
et raconte des salades en fait ils ont
juste pas envie de comprendre parce que
je pense que ils ont à peu près compris
que si ils comprenait ça serait pas
drôle pour eux
alors là dessus on a un problème avec le
climat je vais essayer d'aller vite
première chose que je rappelle le climat
c'est un deux siècles exactement le
changement climatique ça a deux siècles
le premier qui prononce le mot effet de
serre c'est Fourier enfin non c'est même
pas c'est foyer
les deux premiers physiciens qui lisent
c'est le CO2 et la vapeur d'eau c'est
pouillé tinda il y a un siècle et demi
le premier à dire je double le CO2 c'est
plus 4 degrés c'est régnus et la
première fois qu'on a utilisé un modèle
c'était il y a très longtemps alors le
changement climatique je vais pas vous
raconter plein de trucs sur le
changement climatique je pourrais deux
ordres de grandeur que je vais essayer
de faire passer ce soir le premier c'est
le côté fondamentalement non réversible
de l'expérience que nous sommes en train
de vivre à cause de la chimie
foutushimie après foutu physique à cause
de la foutu chimie parce que le CO2 est
un oxyde il se trouve que sur Terre les
oxydes
et les oxydes dans la salle Manille sur
terre dette des formes chimiques stables
c'est même sous forme d'oxyde que vous
trouvez la totalité des métaux
disponibles sur terre dès lors que le
métal à la capacité à s'oxyder c'est la
forme stable donc le CO2 une fois que
vous le mettez dans l'air il est stable
il se trouve très bien là il a aucune
envie de [ __ ] le camp qui tape
l'incruste à la soirée qui juste veut
pas partir c'est exactement ça
surplus de concentration en CO2 que nous
avons créé aujourd'hui
sur plus de concentration que nous avons
créé aujourd'hui si demain matin
j'annulais les émissions mondiales donc
j'arrête totalement d'émettre des gaz à
effet de serre dans le monde quand
j'arrête demain matin
et bien le surplus que nous avons déjà
créé le fait de passer de 280 à 400
parties par millions au bout d'un siècle
il vous reste encore 40% de ce surplus
au bout d'un mille les nerfs il vous
reste encore 20% de ce surplus et au
bout de 10 000 ans il vous en reste
encore 10%
. donc le problème du changement
climatique est un problème dont les
conséquences
pardon je vous ai mis la slide en
anglais oui de temps en temps je fais ça
c'est là je suis distrait
les conséquences de cette affaire vont
très au-delà
très au-delà de l'entendement de la
pensée humaine sur sa propre vie ou
celle des gens qu'on croise tous les
jours c'est-à-dire nos enfants petits
enfants
évidemment démocratie il y a deux ordres
de grandeur entre le pas de temps qui
est pertinent pour ce problème et le pas
de temps qui est pertinent pour un
mandat électoral
deux ordres de grandeur d'accord donc ce
que je suis en train de vous dire là
c'est que il n'existe pas pour le
changement climatique de bouton reset
ça n'a pas plus de sens de penser qu'on
peut appuyer sur le bouton reset pour le
changement climatique que de penser que
le jour où vous jetez déprimé du haut de
la tour Eiffel arriver à 50 mètres du
sol vous dites merde j'aurais pas dû
reset comme dans les jeux vidéo là vous
savez craque pour monter au troisième
étage bon dans les jeux vidéo ça existe
peut-être dans la vraie vie non donc on
est en train de faire une expérience
grandeur nature pour la première fois
s'il y a un moment le résultat de
l'expérience commence à nous déplaire la
seule garantie que vous avez à ce moment
là c'est que ça sera pire derrière
je vais prendre un autre parallèle c'est
un peu comme si vous vous arrêtez de
fumer et à ce moment la seule garantie
que vous avez c'est que les risques
augmentent pendant encore 30 ans
c'est à peu près ça
alors évidemment c'est compliqué pour
l'action quand vous savez ça c'est une
autre manière de dire qu'avec le
changement climatique vous avez
nécessairement avoir peur d'une
construction intellectuelle vous ne
pouvez pas attendre d'avoir peur pour de
vrai si vous voulez être sérieux et vous
devez absolument tout faire puisque les
combustibles fossiles ont tout fait dans
notre vie pour que ça n'arrive pas voilà
vous commencez à avoir une petite idée
de la difficulté de la faire et vous
comprenez évidemment bien que c'est pas
à 200 pays se réunissant une fois par an
pour décider à l'unanimité de ce qu'on
va faire qu'on va y arriver
c'est un peu comme si une fois par an
vous réunissez une assemblée de
copropriétaires de 200 copropriétaires
ou chaque copropriétaire compte pour une
voix quel que soit la surface qu'il
occupe et vous les réunissez en disant
messieurs je ne sais pas exactement
combien je vais vous faire payer mais je
vous demande d'être tous d'accord sur ce
que vous allez faire en sortant de la
pièce à l'unanimité et sens indique pour
diriger les débats
bon je vous laisse au gré du succès de
la ferme
le deuxième ordre de grandeur que je
voudrais vous mettre en tête c'est ce
que représente la variation de
température dont on est en train de
parler vous savez que les médias
arrêtent pas de vous dire on risque de
degré 3 degrés etc alors en fait quand
vous entendez ça vous en foutez
complètement la température à Paris
entre l'hiver et l'été et varie 40
degrés vous êtes tous bien vivant du
reste sinon vous auriez pas venu ici
donc 2 degrés on s'en fout complètement
ça nous parle pas avec nos sens de
degrés c'est vraiment pas une menace
avec nos sens
alors pour illustrer ce que ça peut
vraiment vouloir dire voilà une carte de
l'Europe aujourd'hui si on n'a pas coupé
les écosystèmes installés pour faire la
Cité des Sciences puis tout un tas
d'autres futiles qui servent à rien
comme des champs des routes des endroits
où vivent etc donc si on fout la paix
aux écosystèmes installés nous avons des
forêts en Europe ça veut dire que le
climat est suffisamment doux et
suffisamment tempéré pour que pousse des
grosses espèces végétales qui se sentent
raisonnablement bien quand c'est trop
sec ça pousse pas et quand c'est trop
froid et souvent trop sec aussi ça
pousse pas
voici l'Europe il y a 20 ans il y a 20
000 ans nous sommes au cœur de la
dernière heure glaciaire donc il fait
froid l'Europe est peuplée de mammouth à
poils les nœuds derrière lesquels nous
courons
et vous voyez que la géographie
européenne est un peu différente de la
géographie actuelle il y a une première
bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est pas ni
les finlandais ni les Suédois ni les
Norvégiens enfin ceux-là sont pas
vraiment des nuisances ni les écossais
qui vont nous emmerder au rugby tous ces
braves gens sont sous la glace vous avez
une calotte de 3 km d'épaisseur qui
recouvre toute la Scandinavie qui
recouvre soit du temps passant tout le
Canada qui recouvre pour partie l'Écosse
donc ça mauvaise nouvelle pour les
amateurs de whisky bonne nouvelle pour
les amateurs de rugby vous voyez les
glaciers européens là qui descendent
très très bas etc
cette glace évidemment est constituée
d'eau gelée donc il est l'eau il a bien
fallu la prendre quelque part cette eau
elle vient des océans dont le fond n'a
pas varié donc le niveau de l'eau dans
l'océan a baissé le niveau de l'eau a
baissé de 120 mètres c'est la raison
pour laquelle on pourrait rentrer dans
la grotte Cosquer à pied alors que
aujourd'hui vous avez besoin d'avoir
votre brouette plongée pour rentrer dans
la grotte Cosquer donc l'entrée est sous
marine
alors évidemment le trait de côte est un
tout petit peu différent
les gens qui aiment bien la Manche et
ben ils ont passé leurs vacances
ailleurs il y a pas de manche et le
point bas de la manche est 114 mètres
aujourd'hui plus de manche donc tout ça
a un peu changé
il fait beaucoup plus froid donc il fait
beaucoup plus sec parce que dans un
climat plus froid il y a moins d'eau qui
s'évapore et donc les écosystèmes en
France ressemblent grosso modo à ce que
vous trouvez aujourd'hui au nord de la
Sibérie
et dans ce genre d'écosystème vous
arrivez à faire vivre la population d'un
arrondissement parisien d'aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs les animaux en bout de
chaîne alimentaire qui s'appelle les
hommes il y en a 100000 qui sont
capables de survivre là dedans et bien
quand l'Europe est passée du paysage de
gauche au paysage de droite la planète
dans son ensemble s'est réchauffé de 5
petits degrés
pas 50 et pas 500 5 et ça ça a mis 5000
ans à ce produit
à l'époque les migrations humaines sont
pas vraiment un sujet la démocratie
n'existe pas la taille des sociétés
humaines c'est 200 personnes les
syndiquée à la CGT donc quand le chef de
tribu décide qu'on va changer de
cavernes il prend sa plus belle massue
distribue les baffes tout le monde suit
les quelques récalcitrants sont
rapidement dissuadés de ne pas le faire
et si on perd 30% de la des effectifs de
la tribu au passage c'est pareil il y a
personne pour s'en plaindre ça fait
partie de la vie à l'époque
il est bien évident aujourd'hui qu'un
déplacement des conditions installées or
si vous êtes là dans cette salle une
deuxième raison à laquelle on la doit
c'est que le climat a été
remarquablement stable sur les 10 000
dernières années ce qui a permis aux
hommes de se sédentariser c'est-à-dire
de développer des pratiques culturelles
qu'ils avaient pas besoin de changer
tous les quatre matins parce que le
climat changeait il avait pas besoin
tous les quatre matins de passer du
phoque à la baguette tout simplement
parce que les conditions climatiques
ambiantes changent
et du coup ils ont pu s'installer ce
sédentariser créer les villes et créer
tout ce qui va avec les villes la
comptabilité les systèmes administratifs
etc donc la stabilité du climat a
engendré la quasi-totalité du système de
cohabitation que les hommes ont inventé
au moment où ils sont sédentarisés c'est
là que ça vient
donc depuis 10.000 ans c'est stable mais
vous voyez que quelques degrés en
quelques milliers d'années c'est une
transition absolument massive alors bien
évidemment quelques degrés en un siècle
ou deux c'est une transition encore plus
massive encore plus massive alors je
vous la fais courte maisonne 4 ou 5
degrés sur terre d'élévation en un
siècle c'est à gare partout
je suis prêt à prendre le parier et
engager mes descendants donc je parie
avec qui veut là dans la salle j'espère
qu'on vivra pas l'expérience mais c'est
absolument évident on va déstabiliser le
système à une vitesse telle au surplus à
un moment on aura de moins en moins
d'énergie abondante à notre disposition
pour tout construire les vestiaux je
peux vous le dire c'est le chaos
organisé absolument partout PIB va en
souffrir un peu donc quand monsieur
estern dit 4 degrés de plus on risque 6%
de perdre du PIB je pense qu'il aurait
mieux fait de rajouter un zéro
voire de 600% c'est un peu compliqué
mais
enfin il aurait mis n'importe quoi entre
50 et 100 c'était plus crédible c'est
évident que c'est pas 4% de perte du PIB
alors dans les conséquences si on essaye
de zoomer un peu il va se passer plein
de choses même si c'est très difficile
de les décrire précisément d'abord parce
que l'ampleur de la transformation va
dépendre des émissions résiduelles et
ensuite parce que un modèle c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne à large
maille qu'un risque c'est au croisement
d'une perturbation et d'une capacité de
résistance et que vous ne pouvez pas
spéculer sur la capacité de résistance
future donc tout ça est très compliqué
donc c'est qualitativement qu'il faut
avoir les risques en tête donc il y a un
risque sur la production agricole il y a
un risque sur la stabilité des
écosystèmes qui ont pas besoin de ça il
y a un risque sur la prolifération de
virus et de bactéries qui n'existaient
pas avant il y a un risque sur les
événements extrêmes thermiques il y a un
risque sur l'élévation de l'océan je
vous en parlerai après il y a un risque
sur le pH de l'océan c'est à dire son
côté moins basique que celui qu'il est
aujourd'hui et ça ça va handicaper tous
les organismes qui ont besoin de
synthétiser du calcaire il y a un risque
sur la circulation
océanique à grande échelle celle qui
s'arrête dans le jour d'après là pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont vu alors jour
d'après c'est physiquement totalement
impossible mais ça illustre le fait que
ça peut être un peu brutal il y a un
risque sur l'intensité des ouragans
il y a un risque que je vais en parler
dans pas longtemps sur la
déstabilisation du Groenland et de la
calotte antarctique de l'Ouest en fait
le Groenland a commencé à fondre et
maintenant il continuera à fondre quoi
qu'on fasse jusqu'à la prochaine entrée
en glaciation si elle arrive c'est dans
pour dans 30 que 40 000 ans et ça c'est
trois à 6 m d'eau dans l'océan de
manière certaine et si on dépasse les
deux degrés vous avez également la
calotte antarctique de l'Ouest qui est à
risque et ça c'est 6 mètres d'eau dans
l'océan
alors quand j'y arrive que ça veut dire
que ça se désagrège ça fait des gros
icebergs parce que la calotte est en
pente se termine sur l'eau etc donc
voilà
vous verrez après à quoi ressemble
l'Europe du Nord avec 9 mètres d'eau en
plus il y a un risque sur la remise en
circulation de stock de carbone qui
était fixe depuis des milliers ou des
millions d'années voilà et donc il y a
un risque sur les hommes à l'arrivée et
il y a surtout une incertitude
irréductible sur la capacité à
quantifier ce risque
elle est irréductible cette incertitude
parce que vous ne pouvez pas savoir
quelle est la capacité de réponse des
hommes dans 50 ans et parce que vous ne
pouvez pas savoir quel est l'ampleur de
la perturbation qu'on va encore infliger
au système et parce que ensuite vous
avez des effets papillons dans tous les
sens
moi je suis pas capable de vous dire en
quelle année les États-Unis vont fait ni
vont finir par élire un type encore plus
cinglé que Trump
or ça va faire partie des conséquences
de ce genre de truc
parce que quand vous secouez fort le
système il produit des tasses d'effets
de bord dont vous n'avez pas du tout
envie
donc je le redis lutter contre le
changement climatique ces bandes et tous
ces muscles pour atteindre un objectif
que vous n'êtes pas capable de discerner
avec précision vous savez pas exactement
à quelle distance il est et pourtant
vous n'avez que ça en tête
vous commencez à voir que l'écart avec
la politique qu'on connaît
pose question
je vais passer la question des
précipitations mais dans l'excellent
bouquin que je vous recommande vous
verrez que il y a un petit sujet avec
daesh et je vais aller directement à ça
voilà donc ça c'est une carte de l'océan
montée de 9 mètres en Europe du Nord
donc il suffit de passer les deux degrés
il suffit d'attendre
c'est pas pour la semaine prochaine on
est bien d'accord on est en train de
parler de quelques siècles
ça peut aller plus vite que ce qu'on
s'imagine moins vite plus vite
il y a 10 ans mon ami avait le truc il
était extrêmement prudent dans la
manière de dire peut-être que ça peut
arriver etc aujourd'hui il regrette
parce que quand vous êtes en train de
regarder la vitesse à laquelle un
certain nombre de processus sont en
train de se développer alors qu'on les
attendait pas pour si tôt il se dit bah
j'ai peut-être été bien couillon de dire
aux gens attendez vous précipitez pas
sur les conclusions j'ai peut-être
retardé l'action de ce fait c'est un
vrai cas de conscience qu'est-ce que
vous faites quand vous êtes à sa place
vous sonnez le toxin en disant faut
absolument que les gens se mettent en
branle au risque que dans les 5 ans qui
viennent ils se passent rien ou au
contraire vous dites en toute
rationalité scientifique la barre
d'erreur fait que je peux rien vous
garantir au risque que les gens ne
fassent rien
compliqué compliqué
alors si on veut agir vous avez ici une
deuxième droite cardinale après la
première que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure cette deuxième droite cardinale
elle vous dit quelle est la réponse en
température donc c'est une succession de
simulation mais retenez que c'est une
droite quelle est la réponse en
température du système planétaire en
fonction des émissions cumulées que nous
lui infligerons tout ça va jusqu'en 2100
donc vous démarrez la partie à l'air
pré-industrielle vous cumulez les
émissions jusqu'en 2100 et vous dites à
la boule de cristal c'est quoi
l'élévation de température que j'aurai
entre 1850 et 2100 c'est ça le sens de
ce graphe et donc la boule de cristal
vous dit bah c'est très simple c'est une
fonction linéaire donc par exemple afin
2015 on a déjà émis 2000 milliards de
tonnes de CO2 et donc je te dis que tu
as déjà signé pour 1, quelque chose de
gré même s'ils sont pas là tout de suite
ça ça signait pour donc les 1,5 degrés
qui sont le talon bas de l'accord de
Paris vous oubliez ils sont déjà
derrière nous
c'est fini fallait y penser avant cela
on en est sûr
si vous voulez les deux degrés dont il
est question alors physiquement c'est
encore possible et vous allez voir à
quel contrepartie
à ce moment il faut se limiter à 3000
milliards de tonnes de CO2 donc 2000 ans
déjà été dépensé
d'accord vous avez encore le droit
d'émettre jusqu'en 2100 mille milliards
de tonnes
donc les plus jeunes dans cette salle
jusqu'à la fin de leur jour ont le droit
d'émettre collectivement alors qu'ils
sont 7 milliards enfin quelques
milliards la moitié de ce que leur
grand-parents et leurs parents ont émis
pendant le siècle qui s'est terminée il
y a pas longtemps alors qu'ils étaient
en moyenne trois fois moins nombreux
autrement votre budget carbone par
personne sur le cours de votre vie c'est
un sixième de ce que vos parents et
grands-parents oui
c'est ça les deux degrés
on peut discuter
mais c'est ça les deux
alors ce que vous dit la physique c'est
que à ce moment-là il faut avoir rendu
les émissions mondiales nulles quelque
part dans la deuxième moitié du 21e
siècle d'où l'expression de neutralité
qui commence à arriver partout et il
faut les avoir divisé par 3 d'ici à 2050
donc d'ici à ce que mes enfants et mon
âge
simplicité absolument biblique
d'ici à ce que dans tous les gens qui
ont des enfants dans cette salle
maintenant qu'on les fait à peu près 30
ans et bien d'ici à ce que vos enfants
et votre âge faut avoir divisé les
émissions planétaires par 3
pour faire les deux degrés
bon ça je vais passer parce que j'ai
plus le temps
alors si vous voulez diviser les
émissions par 3
qu'est-ce qu'on divise voilà je vais
finir par ça vous avez aujourd'hui un
camembert qui vous donne la répartition
des émissions planétaires de gaz à effet
de serre grossièrement reconstitué par
votre serviteur en panachant les
énergies les machins les trucs et les
bidules
c'est tout gaz à effet de serre confondu
donc c'est pas juste le CO2 c'est le CO2
le méthane le protoxyde d'azote et les
gaz halogénés que nous émettons
un peu plus de 20% des émissions
planétaires sont le fait des centrales à
charbon vous avez sur terre plus de 2000
gigawatts de centrales à charbon
installés en fonctionnement alors que
vous avez 63 malheureux gigawatts de
nucléaire en France donc 2000 gigawatts
de centrales à charbon dans le monde il
faut toutes les avoir mises à la
ferraille dans les 35 ans qui viennent
pour les avoir remplacés par des sources
sans carbone si on veut régler les deux
degrés toutes
pas 10% en moins toutes j'ai
personnellement quelques doutes quant au
fait qu'on va y arriver juste avec des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes
et quand je dis quelques doutes je parie
pas un centime de mes économies sur le
fait qu'on va y arriver
vous avez 7 % des émissions planétaires
qui sont le fait des centrales à gaz
et un peu affioul vous avez 5 % des
émissions planétaires qui sont le fait
des cimentier
je crois que la farjolsim est le plus
gros émetteur corporate de CO2 sur terre
je crois
une cimenterie c'est un million de
tonnes de CO2 par an
la France c'est 400 donc vous voyez
enfin en ordre de grandeur donc vous
prenez 400 cimenteries 400 usines à
ciment et crack vous avez les émissions
françaises
5% donc la fabrication du ciment donc
construire plein de logements parce que
droit au logement bah c'est aujourd'hui
produire plein de ciment et plein
d'acier
donc c'est craché plein de CO2 qu'est-ce
que je choisis
des conditions de vie difficiles
aujourd'hui pour ce combat de logement
ou l'enfer sur terre demain pour tout le
monde
non mais compliqué qu'est-ce que je
choisis qu'est-ce que vous choisiriez
le reste de l'industrie dans lequel la
Syrie fait à peu près 4% aussi C12 le
reste c'est de la chimie de base et
après le reste c'est des cacahuètes
transférer le plastique une fois vous la
fait vous l'avez fait pardon en cette
bouteille ça c'est pas énormément
d'émissions et transformer l'acier une
fois que vous l'avez fait en boulons de
dose c'est pas énormément d'émissions
non plus ce qui va beaucoup émettre
c'est de faire les matières premières et
là vous êtes limité par des rendements
stoechiométriques donc en général le
gain que vous allez pouvoir faire en
termes d'efficacité énergétique par
unité de matière il est jamais colossal
quand ça sort de minerai quand c'est
recyclé c'est autre chose mais tout
recycle pas
les chaudières de bâtiments c'est 5%
donc en France c'est un gros sujet parce
que on n'a pas des cimenteries et des
astéries qui tournent autant que dans le
reste du monde on n'a pas nos centrales
à charbon on n'a pas de centrales à gaz
puis vous allez voir que le reste est
moins important aussi donc le pare
bâtiment est beaucoup plus important et
puis surtout on est un pays des moyens
de latitude donc on chauffe hiver quand
vous êtes à Singapour vous avez pas de
problème vous pouvez chauffer l'hiver si
vous voulez mais enfin pas tellement
améliorer votre confort thermique
donc les chaudières de bâtiment dans le
monde c'est 5% l'électricité des
bâtiments c'est un morceau de
l'électricité que vous avez là
évidemment mais les chaudières
les transports c'est 14% dans lesquels
vous avez à peu près 6 pour les voitures
alors c'est l'arrondi qui fait que ça
fait pas 14 à peu près 4 pour les
camions à peu près 2 pour les bateaux et
à peu près 2 pour les avions
les cimenteries dans le monde c'est un
problème identique au parc mondial de
camion
les acieries dans le monde c'est un
problème du même ordre de grandeur que
les bateaux et les avions réunis
on va voir ce genre d'ordre de grandeur
en tête donc il suffira pas de c'est un
très bonnes choses à faire mais il
suffira pas de moins prendre l'avion et
de moins prendre sa bagnole pour avoir
réglé le problème
tu verras pas
20% des émissions mondiales sont le fait
de manger alors là dedans qu'est-ce
qu'il y a vous avez les émissions
directes de méthane des ruminants vous
savez que les ruminants émettent du
méthane comme les hommes mal élevés les
femmes sont discrètes
mais c'est les la fermentation entérique
dans les estomacs des ruminants qui sont
supérieurs à nous sur ce plan 4 c'est
très bonne triple ensuite
et donc quand ça fermente là dedans vous
avez du méthane qui ressort et le
méthane est un gaz à effet de serre 28
fois plus puissant que le CO2
vous avez également du protoxyde d'azote
qui est un sous-produit de l'utilisation
des engrais azotés quand on les épend
dans les champs que ces engrais azotés
soient de synthèse ou du reste du lisier
ou des bouses c'est pareil ça émet du
protoxyde d'azote c'est un gaz à effet
de serre vous avez le méthane des
rizières parce que ça décompose des
débris organiques dans les rizières et
vous avez les les émissions de méthane
des déjections voilà je vous rappelle
que le port est un mono gastrique donc
lui il rumine pas quand il y a un comme
ça c'est juste qu'il vous trouve les
rideaux mais à part ça il rumine pas
9 % des émissions planétaires c'est la
déforestation qui est un déterminant
amont de la croissance démographique et
de l'alimentation
tous les pays qui ont déforesté de
manière significative l'Europe inclut
puisque l'Europe il y a 1000 ans c'était
80% de surface forestière il y a 150 ans
c'était 15 % de surface forestière entre
les deux croissance démographique les
États-Unis même motifs même punition et
ce qui se passe en ce moment dans les
pays qui déforètent c'est exactement
pareil c'est une réponse à la croissance
démographique donc on les agronome vous
disent on peut nourrir 9 milliards
d'hommes sur Terre les nourrir sûrement
avec de la biodiversité qui reste ça se
discute
mais c'est un déterminant amont et donc
il y a deux drivers forts à cette
déforestation accroître la part de
viande dans l'alimentation parce qu'il
faut accroître la production végétale
et accroître ta population et enfin vous
avez quelques potes de perlimpinpin pour
finir le reste la gestion des déchets
les chaînes du froid etc et donc
question il faut diviser ça par trois
par où je commence
qu'est-ce que je fais qu'est-ce qui est
plus facile à qui je demande de faire
des efforts comment je le répartis
est-ce que je vais passer par un système
de prix c'est à dire un marché est-ce
que le marché a une capacité à se
projeter à 30 ans ou est-ce que j'oublie
les marchés quand je parle de ce genre
de truc et je dois replanifier re
réguler et avoir un pouvoir central
beaucoup plus fort parce que voilà c'est
ça toutes les questions qu'il faut se
poser à partir de maintenant et bien
évidemment le Yaka faucon
développer les éoliennes plus vite que
les Allemands pour être sortis du
problème non si c'était aussi simple que
ça je serai un homme heureux vous
emmerderez pas avec mes parents horizons
alors il y a les chaleurs qu'il est et
vous pourriez aller directement au
restaurant c'est évidemment un problème
beaucoup plus imbriqué beaucoup beaucoup
plus noué quelque part que ça voilà donc
pour finir par une petite image à mon
avis on n'est pas très loin vous savez
vous rappeler là dans la guerre des
étoiles là ils sont dans les déchets
dans un espace qui se réduit
voilà pas très loin à mon avis c'est un
peu oxygène peut-être alors là à la fin
de l'histoire c'est qu'il retrouve de
l'air au dessus
nous on est dans le vaisseau spatial
lui-même pas compliqué voilà j'ai été
trop long
ce n'est pas moi qui fait les règles de
sécurité de la salle donc si maintenant
on peut rester un peu il y a tout le
temps que vous voulez pour les questions
merci beaucoup Monsieur Jean covici vous
savez qu'à l'extérieur nous avons
installé des sièges grâce aux personnel
de sécurité pour que des personnes
puissent suivre votre conférence dans le
hall donc ne vous inquiétez pas je pense
qu'on peut réellement prendre du temps
et voilà nous allons avant de passer aux
questions excusez-moi
quel est l'excellent livre
plein s'il vous plaît c'est le premier
alors le plus récent qui est commandé
jusqu'en 2016 c'est celui-ci donc dormez
tranquille jusqu'en 2100 vous nous en
avez donné une un petit échantillon tout
à l'heure merci beaucoup en tout cas
pour votre intervention dynamique et
puis avec beaucoup d'humour cela dit
nous ne dormirons plus
parce que nous sommes très inquiets vous
avez compris qu'il fallait jamais faire
de promesses qu'on n'était pas capable
de tenir tout à fait donc
qu'allons-nous faire voilà
au fait et comme peut-être que les
personnes parmi vous ont des enfants et
des petits-enfants moi j'ai un autre
excellent livre à leur faire lire c'est
le changement
climatique expliqué à ma fille donc nous
savons que vous avez une fille à qui
vous avez expliqué le changement
climatique
j'ai une fille qui est allée chercher
des questions dans sa classe le jour où
elle a su que j'avais ce bouquin à
écrire donc elle quand elle a su j'avais
ce bouquin à écrire elle est allée voir
son prof de maths en l'occurrence et
elle lui a dit tiens il y a mon père qui
doit écrire ce bouquin et donc le prof a
demandé à chacun des élèves de sa classe
est en quatrième à l'époque que chaque
élève pose une question et donc j'ai
pris des questions telles qu'elles
étaient posées par les élèves exactement
dans les mêmes mots ou à peu près et
puis donc mon bouquin était fait j'ai
plus qu'à faire la réponse
c'est formidable donc voilà vous avez
une nouvelle édition j'ai rajouté
quelques questions à moi
donc les excellents livres de Monsieur
Jancovici se trouve à la bibliothèque de
la Cité des sciences et de l'industrie
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas il y a
une excellente bibliothèque ici vous
pouvez consulter les ouvrages sur place
où vous inscrire et les emprunter je dis
tout ça parce qu'il y a une collègue
bibliothécaire dans la salle
et ben maintenant je vais vous passer la
parole et vous si vous pouvez poser des
questions courtes s'il vous plaît ce que
je vais faire pardon je vais aller
chercher la main qui est tout au bout là
haut parce que sinon je vais l'oublier
sans vouloir commander personne s'il y a
un deuxième micro un truc qui marche
bien c'est de passer le micro suivant
sur la liste comme ça on perd pas de
temps
allô oui oui alors ma question c'était
par rapport
vous disiez que quand on a émis du CO2
c'est pour 2000 ans
mais quid de l'absorption du CO2 par les
systèmes naturels par exemple les arbres
ou les algues qui sont formés à partir
de carbone en fait vous avez une
dynamique dans l'affaire c'est ce que
j'ai montré là land
update en fait la traduction en français
c'est le puits terrestre donc c'est la
photosynthèse qui vous récupère une
partie du CO2 ensuite
Océane invasion c'est pas les martiens
qui débarquent c'est le l'équilibrage de
pression partielle de CO2 entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan mais c'est ce
qui par ailleurs cause la signification
de l'océan
et enfin la réaction avec le carbonnade
de calcium c'est un processus qui se
passe dans l'océan et qui finit d'épurer
totalement le système avec de la
sédimentation
voilà donc le système réagit mais il met
du temps à réagir donc ça finit par
s'amortir mais c'est long
il y a un quota de question par personne
sinon on va jamais s'en sortir
allô
donc du coup en fait si on plante plus
d'armes ou plus d'algues on peut
accélérer ce phénomène alors planter des
algues c'est compliqué
des arbres oui mais vous avez compris
que pour le moment on a un processus qui
s'oppose à planter des arbres on en
coupe parce que la population augmente
et qu'on mange plus de viande
de décarboner notamment qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du du power to gaz qui
permet de gérer l'électricité
renouvelable en créant du CH4
renouvelable et qui peut être ensuite
utilisé dans les bus de la RATP par
exemple
quand vous allez regarder le rendement
matière et énergétique de ce genre de
filière vous vous rendez compte que vous
allez et dans un système qui a bouclé
c'est à dire que vous n'avez plus du
tout d'énergie fossile dans le système
vous vous rendez compte que ce genre de
truc ça vous permettra pas de maintenir
les niveaux d'approvisionnement
énergétique que vous avez aujourd'hui
donc pour faire avancer les bus de la
RATP si vous méthanisez les déchets
agricoles aujourd'hui vous aurez de quoi
faire si vous voulez que chacun conserve
sa voiture avançant au biogaz vous
oubliez
tout ça est une affaire dans de grandeur
le grand problème des débats sur
l'énergie c'est qu'on parle le chiffre
c'est justement ça le problème donc dans
un débat qui s'installe en général comme
je disais tout à l'heure de manière un
peu caricaturale avec un câlin vous avez
la même pagination dans le journal que
je vous parle d'un bus de la RATP qui
marche au biogaz ou de 10 bus qui marche
au biogaz ou de l'ensemble des voitures
qui marchent au biogaz je veux toujours
vous faire un papier donc vous perdez la
notion des ordres de grandeur avec ce
genre de traitement or ça n'est qu'une
affaire d'ordre de grandeur si je
transpose sur le plan économique qui
nous est plus familier c'est un peu
comme si je vous dis Renaud vend de
moins en moins de voitures mais c'est
pas grave on se rattraper en vendant les
trombones
que je lise beaucoup de papiers enfin
j'ai beaucoup de papiers à mettre
ensemble pour qu'il s'y retrouve bah là
c'est exactement pareil tant que vous
avez pas été regardé dans le détail vous
ne savez pas si vous êtes en train de
parler d'une mesure qui est principale
de niche donc elle est très bonne
approche mais vous n'en ferez pas une
mesure principale ou un truc qui vous
aggrave le problème ce que vous faites
de temps en temps enfin vous pas vous en
particulier mais ce que les pouvoirs
publics décident de temps en temps
je me présente en fait il y avait un
point qui m'intéressait c'est de savoir
quel est votre objectif ce soir
nous présenter ça et nous du coup
individuellement qu'elle devrait être
notre objectif alors mon objectif ce
soir c'est que on m'a demandé de venir
causer et que j'ai dit oui
et que c'est toujours rigolo de venir
causer plus sérieusement mon objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que vous ayez
plus de questions en sortant de la salle
quand on est rentrant
et à partir du moment où vous allez
avoir envie de vérifier par vous même ce
que j'ai raconté et de commencer à
essayer de comprendre par vous même les
implications de tout ça j'ai gagné parce
que ça vous quittera plus
j'ai gagné au sens de j'apporte un
bénéfice à la collectivité parce que
vous allez avoir envie je l'espère de
vous en parlez avec un peu de hauteur de
vue du problème et derrière les
solutions ça sera les autres
moi je vais pas vous dire si vous devez
manger moins de viande ou prendre moins
l'avion ou faire les deux enfin ou faire
un métier qui consiste à essayer
d'apporter une solution au problème
chaque encore une fois
le seuil de la douleur on va dire dans
l'action individuelle il peut être placé
dans des endroits très différents selon
les individus dans ma boîte qui
s'appelle carbone 4 parce qu'en fait
l'essentiel de ce qui m'occupe c'est une
boîte qui s'appelle carbone 4 donc il
n'est pas une agence publicitaire pardon
ce qui a été dit de conseil
et bien le il y a des gens qui sont
extrêmement engagés dans leurs actes
quotidien et il y en a d'autres qui
considèrent que avec le métier qui font
ça va bien ils peuvent manger du veau à
midi c'est donc c'est vraiment voilà
donc j'ai pas à vous donner le seuil de
votre douleur ce que j'espère c'est que
vous allez le trouver par vous-même
quelque part et avoir envie de faire
quelque chose de ça notamment le fait de
le vérifier par vous-même
moi j'ai une question devant la gravité
et la clarté des faits j'ai une question
qui est plus compliquée que ce qu'elle
en a l'air pourquoi est-ce que les gens
ne sont pas au courant en fait de la
gravité des choses est-ce que c'est par
l'aubier économique par peur politique
est-ce que c'est une peur de la panique
générale est-ce que
vos éléments de réponse par quels sont
vos éléments de réponse par rapport à ça
il y a trois manières
non il y a deux manières de diffuser
largement l'information dans une société
et il y en a pas d'autres vous êtes et
je vous en remercie ce soir quelques
centaines à être venu
je suis sûr tiens je vais demander à
tous ceux qui m'ont déjà entendu en
conférence de lever la main
voilà donc vous auriez mieux fait de
rester chez vous vous avez rien appris
d'accord
donc et c'est les mêmes qui vont acheter
mes bouquins et c'est les mêmes qui vont
aller farfouiller sur mon site internet
etc donc j'ai fait un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur une fois j'ai regardé j'ai mis
bout à bout toutes les ventes de livres
que j'ai faites je dois être à 50.000 ou
un truc comme ça mais les gens achètent
tous les bouquins donc voilà donc j'ai
causé via mes livres aller à 30000
personnes c'est le bout du monde si je
fais une conférence par semaine à 200
personnes et ben vous êtes capable de
faire comme moi 10000 personnes à la fin
de l'année mais c'est les mêmes
bouge pas et puis si je fais un site
internet j'ai 5000 visites par jour mais
c'est les mêmes
donc ma vie durant j'ai pas l'intention
d'être immortel et bien j'aurais causé à
quoi quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes cent mille personnes peut-être
bon il y a 30 millions 40 millions
d'électeurs dans ce pays donc je ne
compte pas dans l'information globale de
l'électeur je ne compte pas compte pas
aucune importance là où je vais pouvoir
compter c'est dans un autre type
d'information je vais venir juste après
mais les lecteurs je ne compte pas
ce qui compte pour informer les lecteurs
vous avez deux systèmes et deux
seulement vous avez l'éducation et les
médias et un troisième intermédiaire qui
est votre formation continue dans le
cadre de votre boulot donc les trois
endroits où on va vous apprendre des
choses en quantité significative c'est
quand vous passez par l'école là ça
concerne tout le monde depuis que on a
dit que c'était obligatoire sauf
quelques-uns qui vont pas mais vous avez
un deuxième endroit où on informe en
gros tout le monde c'est ce que j'ai
tout à l'heure sur un sujet est un débat
national si sur 20 heures de TF1 donc
voilà 8 millions enfin non maintenant ça
a baissé 6 millions de personnes tous
les soirs enfin vous rajoutez France 2
machin vous en avez encore 15 tous les
soirs d'accord moi toute ma vie 50000
personnes
donc le le sujet ne diffuse pas parce
que les canaux principaux d'information
qui permettraient à l'information de
diffuser ne sont pas mobilisés
alors première option vous dites ça doit
passer par l'Éducation nationale le
temps que vous ayez convaincu les gens
qui font les programmes qui font que les
mecs qui font qu'il faut changer les
cours que ceux-ci que cela qui fasse
trois fois vous avez passé 25 ans quoi
non donc c'est un processus qui va aller
très très lentement et puis le jour où
vous dites faut faire plus d'espace à ce
truc là les profs de maths vont dire de
quoi moins d'espace pour mon cours parce
que là les 24 heures par jour ça bouge
pas c'est une limite physique
donc les profs de maths vont dire de
quoi de quoi les profs de SVT enfin
encore que normalement ça les concerne
d'en dire de quoi de quoi les profs de
français vont dire de quoi de quoi déjà
ils savent pas lire alors vous avez pas
me supprimer du français les profs
d'anglais vont vous dire de quoi de quoi
le monde se mondialiste internationalise
on va pas arrêter de leur apprendre de
l'anglais etc vous le mettez où le bon
moi j'enseigne à des ingénieurs je leur
fais 24 heures de cours et j'estime
qu'au bout de 24 heures de cours j'ai
effleuré le sujet
vraiment j'ai effleuré le sujet je suis
allé un peu plus en profondeur que ce
que je fais derrière garder si vous avez
quelques nuits blanches mais les cours
sont en ligne donc vous allez voir la
répétition de ce truc là un peu plus
délayé mais 24 heures bon pour
correctement un cours d'économie et vous
vous en bouffez toute votre vie c'est
des centaines des milliers d'heures
d'accord donc on est pas du tout égalité
donc le donc la quantité d'espace qu'il
faudrait libérer pour le reste pour que
ça devienne mainstream dans l'éducation
nationale je pense que vous serez mort
et c'est pas sûr qu'on y sera déjà après
vous avez un deuxième sujet ce sont les
médias alors il se trouve que les médias
sont pour l'essentiel d'entre eux et
ceux qui ne le sont pas singes les
autres des entreprises commerciales
une entreprise commerciale a besoin
d'équilibrer ses charges et ses recettes
et du reste quand on s'appelle monsieur
dry s'il est recettes peuvent être très
significativement supérieures aux
charges de manière structurelle on n'est
pas mécontent donc vous avez un sujet
dans les médias qui est de maximiser les
recettes pour ça vous avez devoir la pub
et l'abonnement dans les deux cas de
figure
vous faites venir les gens s'ils ont
envie de venir donc si vous voulez leur
servez une messe millénariste tous les
soirs les 1% de masochistes dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure vous les ferez
venir les autres
je vais quand même regarder plus belle
la vie
à tous les sens du terme donc le donc
c'est compliqué parce que
dire des choses de manière crue dans ces
endroits là c'est prendre le risque de
faire fuir les lecteurs ou les
spectateurs ou les auditeurs donc vous
noyez le poisson vous mettez toujours en
face de quelqu'un qui est susceptible de
dire un truc qui dérange quelqu'un qui
dérange moins enfin voilà ça mais on
s'adapte à la population telle qu'elle
est
il faut aller chercher les gens là où
ils sont à partir du moment où les gens
ils ont la possibilité de zapper vous
leur dites des horreurs ils vont
ailleurs je veux dire après une journée
de boulot vous faites partie des CSP+
comme moi j'imagine mais enfin quand
vous rentrez de l'usine ou du chant
après une journée de boulot ou d'un vous
avez trié des feuilles de maladies à la
sécu toute la journée peut-être que le
discours millénariste pas vraiment voilà
donc ça veut dire que les médias de
l'intelligence supérieure pour être
capable de loger ce discours d'une
manière habile et sympathique et joyeuse
etc bon c'est pareil c'est comme pour
l'éducation nationale le temps qu'on y
arrive il sera passé 20 ans voilà donc
il est là votre problème il est dans le
fait que les processus qui sont
spontanément à l'oeuvre dans un monde
qui a été pensé sans limite ne vous
permettent pas de remettre rapidement de
la limite dans le discours non non vous
n'êtes plus au micro c'est aussi c'est
aussi une limite ne vous permettent pas
de remettre rapidement de la limite
parce que c'est ça dont il s'agit
finalement moi je suis en train de vous
expliquer qu'il y a des limites et qui
va bien falloir s'en accommoder
alors le sol le sol message qui peut
passer c'est quand on s'adresse aux
corps intermédiaires qu'ont deux heures
devant eux pour écouter un problème
compliqué qui sont capables d'en faire
parce qu'ils agissent déjà sur un
environnement proche voilà donc c'est
pour ça que c'est ma cible au travers du
chiffre project c'est assez Jean là que
j'ai envie de parler parce que là je
peux avoir un peu de prise sur le
phénomène pas pour être dictateur mais
parce que je pense que ça va faire
quelque chose
comme dit un de mes amis on parle aux
gens qui peuvent quelque chose
il y avait pas de question qui devait
venir
oui moi j'aurais voulu vous poser une
question concernant le modèle World 3
qui vient des limites de la croissance
et dont les prédictions sont quand même
apocalyptiques je pense qu'on peut le
dire donc eux ils voyaient en tout cas
le modèle business à jujua celui qu'on a
l'air de suivre le scénario qu'on a
l'air de suivre a l'air de prédire un
effondrement de civilisation dans les
années 2030 entre 2030 2040 je voulais
savoir ce que vous pensez de ça parce
qu'il y a eu quand même quelques études
qui ont leur demander que l'effet colle
assez bien en modèle notamment celle de
Turner donc je serai curieux de
connaître votre opinion là-dessus
[Rires]
c'est que la ligne de pente nous emmène
pas nécessairement vers un long fleuve
tranquille
donc World 3 pour ceux d'entre vous qui
sont pas familiers de et méloz pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont pas familiers non
plus mais dose était un scientifique du
MIT qui a travaillé dans une équipe qui
n'avait pas fondé du récit forestter qui
avait fondé l'équipe et qui faisait de
la dynamique des systèmes et à un moment
cet homme qui devait avoir des nuits un
peu trop longues s'est demandé comment
les raccourcir et donc il s'est dit je
vais essayer de faire un modèle qui
représente la dynamique du système
population humaine dans son
environnement donc il a fait un modèle
dans lequel il a une population qui est
comment dire qui a ses propres
déterminants elle cherche à s'alimenter
elle cherche à profiter de service
industriel etc et puis elle est limitée
parce que l'environnement peut lui
offrir c'est à dire il y a une limite de
surface cultivable de ressources
extractives etc et puis maintenant ils
regardent comment est-ce que le système
peut évoluer compte tenu de la manière
dont il a déjà évolué jusqu'à maintenant
et il en tire une conclusion cardinale
une seule il dit tant que l'humanité a
pour objectif de croître
en volume donc plus de monde consomme en
plus la seule chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que à un moment ou un
autre le système s'effondre sur lui-même
après avoir bouffé tout le capital qui
l'entoure
alors il y a deux manières de bouffer le
capital vous pouvez le bouffer par
l'extraction ou vous pouvez bouffer par
la pollution
la pollution perturbant enfin dégradant
la qualité des actifs restants voilà
c'est ce qu'a dit
quel que soit l'optimisme que je puisse
prendre sur les conditions initiales la
quantité de ressources extractives etc
si les hommes cherchent la croissance ou
même la cherche trop longtemps il la
cherche jusqu'en 1980 après ils disent
NON je m'arrête et bien à ce moment le
système finit par s'effondrer sur
lui-même
alors la façon dont le système
s'effondre c'est que à un moment
l'alimentation disponible par personne
se met à baisser les services
industriels disponibles par personne se
mettent à baisser et puis la population
se met à baisser et tout ça de manière
subie alors évidemment mais l'autre il a
pas dit à quel moment tel pays fera la
guerre à tel autre pays etc vous savez
que vous avez que trois manières de
faire mourir les gens c'est la famille
de la maladie la guerre
il a pas d'autres donc une contraction
rapide de la population c'est un monde
dans lequel se généralise des famines
des maladies les guerres
malheureusement assez arithmétique donc
ce qu'on est en train de jouer avec la
prévention des grands problèmes que j'ai
évoqués tout à l'heure c'est ça c'est ça
dont on parle on est en train de jouer
la prévention de la famine de la maladie
et de la guerre voilà je sais pas si
c'est pas des problèmes un peu plus
importants que l'intelligence
artificielle d'un côté et si par
ailleurs cette justifierait pas qu'on
augmente un peu le prix de l'essence et
d'un certain nombre d'autres denrées que
nous trouvons aujourd'hui à gogo voilà
mais mon arbitrage personnel en tout cas
je pense que de poser le problème comme
ça ça fait un peu réfléchir
question par ici dans une conférence
intitulée énergie et climat qu'est-ce
qu'on fait Président vous disiez la
quantité de gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture dans un pays donné est une
fonction inverse de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne est-ce que
c'était une image à des fins
pédagogiques ou une relation
mathématique confirmée par l'histoire
des faits en ce sens est-ce que vous
pensez comme l'écrivait Philippe
Debrosse à la fin des années 80 que nous
redeviendrons paysan pour l'avenir de
nos enfants alors je pense que si vous
attendez suffisamment longtemps un jour
effectivement ce qu'il restera de
l'espèce humaine redeviendra paysanne
oui je sais pas vous dire quand et je
sais pas vous dire par quel processus
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui
la productivité agricole du début du 19e
siècle ne permet pas d'installer sur la
terre 7 milliards d'individus
donc on en revient exactement au propos
précédent faut bien voir que les
combustibles nous ont permis là où ça a
fait entre guillemets entièrement
Malthus parce que moi je me suis arrêté
à essai sur le principe de population
avant d'avoir vu ces calculs savants sur
à quel moment le système s'arrête donc
j'ai lu toute la partie avant très
intéressante notamment toutes ces tables
de mortalité dans lesquelles il explique
à quel âge les gens meurent dans les
diverses régions du monde en 1800
et de quoi mais c'est passionnant mais
par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est que ce qu'a fait
mentir Malthus c'est qu'on est découvert
les combustibles fossiles donc on a
remplacé les animaux de trait qui
mangent du sol par des esclaves qui
mangent du sous-sol donc on a libéré
toutes l'espace pour nous et par
ailleurs on a augmenté la productivité
du sol parce que Malthus n'avait pas vu
venir grâce au combustible
le voilà mais ça a déplacé l'échéance
oui j'ai une question
vous dit alors une première étape pour
que les choses évoluent c'est d'informer
et donc ce que vous faites notamment
mais on voit bien par exemple avec le
rapport medows qu'en fait il y a des
personnes qui ont été informées à un
moment donné et qui ont fait en sorte
d'enterrer ces informations puisqu'il
n'a pas été diffusé donc en fait une
fois qu'on a informé il peut y avoir un
autre blocage et comment on peut agir
sur le blocage qui est des personnes qui
sont en mesure de diffuser largement des
informations et qu'il est diffusent pas
alors je pense que la raison je me suis
longtemps posé la question de savoir
pourquoi est-ce que mes doses avait pas
engendré une école académique parce que
pour ceux d'entre vous qui l'ont lu et
il faut lire l'édition originale dans
son jus en 72 c'est un bouquin il y a
pas une virgule à changer enfin c'est
c'est lumineux un des bouquins les plus
magistraux que j'ai lu
et donc la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce que ce type qui avait contribué à
un travail brillantissime ou à mon avis
du reste pour établir plus que l'égalité
des sexes je crois que c'est pas un
hasard qui l'ai mis sa femme en premier
je crois que c'était aussi quelqu'un
d'extrêmement brillant mais elle est
morte
et bien la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce que il a pas engendré une école
de pensée parce que en fait la seule
manière de faire durer
quelque chose de cette nature c'est
d'installer cette pensée dans un corps
constitué qui résiste au temps qui est
toujours là pour dire des choses et pour
évoluer et en fait j'ai fini par arriver
à une conclusion personnelle que je vous
propose je suis pas complètement sûr de
mon coup mais c'est ce que je crois je
crois que l'affaire c'est perdu dans les
sables alors il a été extrêmement lu le
rapport du Club de Rome ça a été je
crois quoi 10 ou 20 millions
d'exemplaires enfin je veux dire ça a
été un truc extrêmement lu mais la
raison pour laquelle ça n'a rien
engendré d'autres c'est que medows
n'avait pas de clients c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a pas de mettre du monde et donc
quand vous vous intéressez au sort du
monde dans son ensemble vous n'avez
personne en face qui vous dit ah c'est
intéressant creuse donc je vais voir ce
que je peux en faire
il n'y a pas de maître du monde et la
raison pour laquelle les économistes
classiques qui pourtant vous l'avez
compris tout à l'heure en filigranes
quand ils utilisent des modèles
macroéconomiques racontent juste du
grand n'importe quoi je vous invite par
exemple à aller regarder les projections
macroéconomiques de tous les organismes
de place et de confronter ça à ce qui
s'est vraiment passé donc vous prenez
les projections il y a un an il y a 2
ans il y a 3 ans il y a 4 ans il y a 5
ans il y a 10 ans puis regarder ce qui
s'est vraiment passé c'est à pissé de
rire normalement si vous voulez faire
des économies budgétaires tous ces gens
là vous les foutez à la porte c'est
juste à rien et bien vraiment c'est rien
bon et j'utilise un modèle faux à cause
de ce que j'ai raconté tout à l'heure
sauf que eux ils ont des clients parce
que comme ils prétendent raconter des
choses juste à l'échelle d'une maille où
il y a des gens pour agir c'est à dire
des pays eux ils ont des clients donc
eux ils ont un business
donc mes doses ce qui lui a manqué à
l'époque c'est d'être capable de
désagréger son mode de pensée à
l'échelle d'un pays et alors évidemment
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué parce
que les ressources sur la terre vous
pouvez pas les faire venir de Mars pas
beaucoup alors que les ressources dans
un pays vous pouvez les faire venir du
pays d'à côté donc rendre le modèle de
medoz pertinent à la maille d'un pays
c'était prendre en compte et flux d'un
port export etc enfin tout un tas de
trucs que mes doses ne savaient pas
prendre en compte donc c'est pour ça à
mon avis que il a été bloqué dans sa
ligne de pensée
aujourd'hui il a un disciple lointain
qui est un ami qui s'appelle Gael Giraud
qui est en train d'essayer de refermer
dose mais à lui avec un modèle
macroéconomique qui s'applique à la
maille d'un pays donc s'il y arrive un
il méritera peut-être le prix Nobel
enfin qui n'est pas le prix Nobel je
vous rappelle qui est le prix de la
Banque de Suède en la mémoire d'Alfred
Nobel c'est pas un prix Nobel comme les
autres
c'était vraiment des coquins ces
économiste et le
indépendamment de ça il aura recréé du
méloz mais à l'échelle d'un pays
alors évidemment il aura recréé du
mélose avec les mêmes conclusions
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment la fête
s'arrête donc là il faudra voir s'il a
des clients
j'avais une question
c'est ici je suis là c'est
alors
mes questions donc je suis consultant
dans le développement durable chez un de
vos concurrents c'est juste pour gagner
du temps sur la réponse suivante
alors donc j'ai compris que nous sommes
à l'aube d'une crise humanitaire sans
précédent que pensez-vous d'utiliser le
terrorisme ou la crise des migrants qui
sont des sujets racoleur par les médias
français
en disant qu'avec la crise
environnementale nous risquons la même
chose en x 10 x 100 x 1000 à l'échelle
de ludwi donc ça c'est ma première
question et la deuxième qui est très
liée comme c'est la vie et pas la
planète qui est menacée que pensez-vous
d'une solution humaniste pour aligner
les volontés plutôt qu'une solution
environnementaliste pour sauver
l'humanité alors je suis content de voir
que il faut venir chez carbone 4 plutôt
que chez les concurrents parce que la
réponse à la première question elle est
dans une autre conférence que vous
pouvez trouver en ligne qui s'appelle le
daesh à la cop21 voilà donc je vous
invite à aller la voir et aller dans un
des chapitres du bouquin que j'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure dans mes
tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 et la réponse
à la deuxième question c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'organisation mondiale humaniste
donc le problème de celui qui pilote
l'action reste entier
il y a pas de pilote
il peut y avoir un concept car il y a
pas de pilote
bonsoir je suis là tout à fait à gauche
voilà j'ai compris donc je pense comme
la plupart des gens que le on va pas
réduire l'augmentation la consommation
sur terre avant quelques milliers
d'années alors en ce qui concerne le
dégâts on va pas réduire la consommation
quelques milliers d'années
en Europe ça a commencé oui en Europe
oui et dans le monde ça c'est dans
quelques dizaines d'années tout au plus
ceci bon alors en ce qui concerne
vous êtes plus positif que moi en ce qui
concerne le problème climatique
l'échauffement
climatique est-ce qu'il est inimaginable
de penser qu'un jour la chimie
puisse transformer les tagazeux de ce
qu'on dégage dans l'atmosphère en
captation par exemple solide en
transformant le gaz en solide et à ce
moment-là on aurait presque
toute seule sauf que dans l'intervalle
vous serez mort
c'est à dire que ça
c'est de la chimie
ça c'est de la photochimie il vous faut
de l'énergie il faut un photon ça c'est
l'équilibrage de pression partielle
c'est de la physique mais ça c'est de la
chimie
mais vous serez mort
j'ai mis très bien tout seul mais non
mais de la chimie artificielle je veux
dire alors vous y arriverez pas parce
que l'énergie que vous devez mettre en
œuvre pour que cette chimie opère est
supérieure en gros
à enfin engendrer des émissions
supérieures à ce que vous allez
arriverez à les récupérer
et ça c'est encore cette foutue loi de
conservation de l'énergie qui fait que
ça va marcher comme ça
ici vous avez peut-être minimiser un peu
votre capacité d'influence sur la
politique puisque il y a quelques années
vous étiez dans un même club je sais
plus c'était une action ou un club que
Nicolas Hulot qui maintenant au pouvoir
dans le domaine qui nous concerne est-ce
que c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui ou
dans quelle mesure vous avez encore
quelqu'un fluence sur les politiques en
général peut-être puis en particulier on
essaye d'en avoir
alors moi j'ai jamais
la démocratie est un système remontant
on ne le dira jamais assez donc je donc
dans les lectures magistrales que je
conseille à tout le monde
à part la bonne physique il y a le enfin
la bonne physique vulgarisée il y a la
de la démocratie en Amérique de ce cher
Tocqueville qui vous explique le sait
qu'une démocratie non mais c'est
fabuleux c'est le meilleur anthologie de
la société humaine enfin de la
démocratie que je connaisse et
Tocqueville dit que c'est un système
remontant donc en fait en démocratie
vous commencez à agir de manière
significative une fois que vous avez
compris qu'une large partie de la
population vous demandez de le faire
c'est dans ce sens là que ça marche
alors vous avez un point d'ancrage
intermédiaire c'est ce que j'ai appelé
les corps intermédiaires les corps
intermédiaires c'est quoi c'est votre
patron enfin c'est les dirigeants
d'entreprises et les hauts
fonctionnaires c'est etc ces gens-là ils
sont intermédiaires pourquoi parce que
vers le bas entre guillemets ils ont de
l'influence contrairement à ce que
peuvent raconter d'aucun syndicalistes
énervé la majeure partie des Français
ont de bonnes relations avec leur chef
direct au boulot
donc ils font confiance la majeure
partie
et par ailleurs vous avez une petite
capacité d'action vers le haut parce que
quand vous êtes dans ce genre de
position les gens qui sont au-dessus
vous écoutent un peu quand même d'accord
donc c'est à cet endroit là pour moi
c'est à cet endroit que ça se joue dans
une dans une démocratie mais donc la
capacité d'influence sur les politiques
pour moi elle est sur les lectorat ou
sur les lobbys
c'est là donc l'électoral je touche pas
à ça beaucoup trop petit pour voilà
Hulot il avait la stature pour moi je on
a fait on a eu la main sur une enquête
l'autre jour sur l'audience des King
tanks je sais plus qui nous a mis ça
entre les pattes plus comment ça vous
est arrivé là c'est pas nous qui
l'avions demandé et donc il y a 4 % je
crois des quatre supérieures qui
connaissent de chiffres project et 6%
des cas de supérieures qui ne
connaissent moins et les cas de
supérieures c'est quoi c'est 15 20% de
la population active voilà donc je peux
pas jouer au jeu de Hulot je ne cherche
pas du reste mais c'est juste pour dire
j'ai même pas la peine d'essayer le le
jeu auquel on peut jouer donc pour
influencer sur les politiques quand on
est dans ma position c'est d'essayer de
temps en temps de leur suggérer une
construction qui va faire leur bonheur
c'est à dire leur notoriété ou leur
gloire à court terme
négocier un peu d'une manière faustienne
contre un truc qui est cranté dans
l'avenir voilà ça le jeu auquel on peut
jouer et puis essayer de convaincre des
gens qui eux-mêmes ont un pouvoir de
pression que c'est bien qui demande ça
donc si je vais voir pour ne pas
dénommer Saint-Gobain en leur disant
vous savez vous auriez intérêt à ce
qu'on montre le prix du gaz parce que du
coup on va vous acheter plus d'isolant
ça ils peuvent comprendre ils peuvent
dire sur le ministre de l'Énergie
montez-nous le prix du gaz on a envie
vous pouvez aller voir Monsieur
pouyanais pas tant de Total qui vont du
gaz qui ne vend pas de charbon qui a
compris que pour que les centrales
européennes passent du charbon au gaz il
faut mettre 30 euros la tonne de CO2
c'est ce qui commence à faire un
équilibrage des coûts de combustible et
à ce moment il se répond partout
monsieur pouyadey en disant mettez-moi
la tonne de CO2 à 30 euros
voilà et il a un peu plus d'audience que
moi
donc on parlait tout à l'heure d'un je
crois d'un enregistrement non on parlait
pas ici il y a eu une table ronde il y a
pas longtemps ou journée de l'économie à
Lyon dont la vidéo traîne sur Youtube
alors allez la voir pas pour moi parce
que vous apprendrez rien mais allez la
voir parce que des années qui était à la
table ronde c'est très intéressant ce
qui raconte il dit qu'il le porte-voit
des intérêts qu'il défend donc tant
qu'il était à la tête de la branche
Raffinage il était contre l'augmentation
du prix audit CO2 parce que c'est dû
augmenter ses charges de manière massive
le jour où il est devenu patron total et
qu'il a compris que ça lui faisait
vendre du gaz il est devenu pour
c'est non mais moi j'adore ce genre de
personnage parce que au moins il est pas
malhonnête le mec vous dit pourquoi il
propose moi je préfère de très loin ça
au focus parce que lui au moins il vous
permet de comprendre
on peut considérer que vous n'aimez pas
le personnage mais au moins avec lui
vous comprenez avec le focus en plus
vous comprenez rien
donc
il est focu tout ce que vous comprenez
donc le
la question de la pression sur le
politique et une question qui est très
complexe en démocratie et puis il faut
bien comprendre que la démocratie c'est
une pyramide inversée
c'est à dire que dans une entreprise il
y a une vraie pyramide moi si un de mes
salariés fait n'importe quoi je le vis
heureusement ça m'arrive pas souvent
alors
idole il va au prud'hommes très bien je
perdrai 6 mois de salaire mais je peux
quand même le foot dehors vrai pouvoir
de coercition
dans une démocratie vous c'est l'inverse
c'est vous qui dites je veux bien de toi
comme président
ok à renverser
donc le l'influence sur le politique en
fait il faut pas la surestimer c'est de
là je voulais en venir j'en ai pas
essentiellement j'ai de l'influence sur
les gens qui ont de l'influence sur les
politiques un peu
comme ça
parce que au bout du bout quand il faut
choisir entre le compte de résultat
est-ce que je raconte si les deux sont
antagonistes je peux vous dire que c'est
vite
mais c'est leur mandat c'est vraiment
l'article 1832 du Code civil vous dit la
société est faite pour gagner de
l'argent
en parlant de ne pas être malhonnête si
aujourd'hui je suis très très riche à la
lumière de ce que vous venez de raconter
je le suis pas c'est une hypothèse à la
mettre mon argent dans les Paradise
papers ça me semble totalement stupide
donc j'en fais quoi et vous vous arrivez
à parler à des gens qui sont justement
des chefs d'entreprise ou des gens qui
ont des certains moyens d'action
financier pour rediriger les
investissements on essaye une petite un
grave que j'ai pas vu dans votre
présentation mais dans un rapport
d'Oxfam
montre qu'en fait les émissions de CO2
au niveau de la planète si vous découpez
la population mondiale les 7 milliards
en tranches de 10%
10 tranches de 10% la tranche supérieure
de 10% serait responsable de 49% des
émissions de CO2 du coup une réduction
massive de la population si on va
chercher le 10% le plus bas et que on
les élimine par une guerre ou une famine
ça va pas faire grand chose donc ça
aussi en rapport avec comment on fait
agir les plus riches et comment on les
fait maigrir ça va ça va faire que les
pauvres font que les riches sont riches
sur les c'est parce que les 10% les plus
riches font bosser tous les autres que
ils sont riches donc si vous supprimez
tous les autres je suis un peu immoral
dans ce que je raconte mais vous touchez
aussi à la fortune des gens qui sont
riches système est assis mais peu
importe
je reviens ce que j'ai tout à l'heure il
y a deux manières de réduire les
inégalités
vous pouvez faire ça ça ou n'importe
quoi d'intermédiaire si vous demandez
leur avis au riche ils vont plutôt avoir
envie de vous dire ça à la rigueur enfin
plutôt ça
sauf que ça flotte pas dans le contexte
que je vous ai exprimé donc j'en reviens
presque à la question précédente au fond
quel est le pouvoir de coercition réelle
des gens élus en démocratie pour dire
aux riches je vais te piquer 90% de ce
que tu possèdes
il est faible il est d'autant plus
faible que à cause j'ose le mot d'une
intoxication sur l'économie de marché
dont nous sommes victimes depuis 50 ans
avec le consentement du consommateur qui
a d'ailleurs de vous tous qui a très
court terme il a trouvé son compte
nous avons créé un système dont on ne
plus sortir qui est celui de la liberté
d'investissement de circulation etc et
donc maintenant vous êtes en compétition
permanente avec tout le monde sur la
planète dès que vous avez un truc qui se
balade
alors pour les céréales et de ciment ça
va encore donc là vous pouvez mettre des
règles différenciées cimentiers vont
vous dire ouais ouais si on a 50 euros
la tonne on va apporter tout le ciment
juste pas possible les volumes mais par
contre dès que vous avez des trucs qui
va le faire par unité de poids
ça se balade donc des localiser les
chaussettes les voitures
les bagues les alliances faites ce que
vous voulez
donc à ce moment n'importe quel acteur
économique qui ne paye pas ces
externalités gagne sur un acteur qui les
paye
que l'externalité soit sociale ou
environnementale soit dit en passant
donc vous avez un vrai sujet
sans vouloir faire du marxisme
trotskiste je sais pas quoi guevariste
primaire vous avez un vrai sujet dans
cette histoire qui comment est-ce que
j'arrive à freiner les échanges mondiaux
et là c'est pareil vous voyez bien que
si vous lisez les échos tous les jours
ce que je fais et bien dès que les
échanges mondiaux sont freinés tout le
monde se lamente
nous sortons la grande pitié de sa
grotte en lui disant piti que peut-on
faire pour relancer les échanges
mondiaux
donc le
problème à régler
il est comme ça pour le moment avec
l'essentiel des conventions dont on
s'est doté
or une convention ça fait une société
c'est ça qui fait une société c'est une
convention
il y a un économiste de mes amis qui
savent de mes amis si je l'aime bien
non mais je veux dire je suis pas je le
connais pas depuis très longtemps mais
je veux dire je pense qu'on est assez
connivent dans notre manière de
réfléchir qui s'appelle yvareland qui
est un économiste qui a fait partie des
fondateurs de dauphines
et il va à dire un truc un jour qui est
il apparaissait
pas pensé avant mais après c'est devenu
une évidence il a dit on ne réglera pas
ce problème sans que ça devienne une
norme sociale dit autrement j'ai jamais
cherché à justifier par le prix que vous
n'aviez pas le droit de tuer votre
voisin à gauche là au motif que il
m'avait posé une question stupide vous
avez pas le droit
et je vous dis pas si vous avez le droit
de le faire mais c'est 50000 euros
je vous dis pas ça je vous dis interdit
est-ce que dit Var c'est tant que le
changement climatique ou plus exactement
notre aide notre relation à
l'environnement ce qui était le cas dans
les temps anciens je rappelle qu'à
l'époque où la ressource était rare est
contingentes le type qui se servait trop
violemment il était pendu bon
vous voyez une pomme vous étiez vous
étiez pendu enfin je veux dire c'est bon
donc là la
convention dont on s'est doté la
convention économique ne permettant pas
de résoudre le problème il faut que ça
devienne une norme sociale c'est-à-dire
qu'on dise la question de ce que ça
coûte n'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est l'efficacité de la
dépense donc je commence par aller au
moins cher pour régler mon problème mais
le fait que je dois régler le problème
je ne cherche pas à justifier par une
règle économique
dit autrement c'est un domaine dans
lequel je peux tenir un raisonnement
coût efficacité je n'ai pas le droit de
tenir un raisonnement coup bénéfice si
je veux avancer
voilà c'est pour ça que quand monsieur
Stern a dit si on n'agit pas ça sera 6%
du PIB il a rendu un cadeau empoisonné à
la cause le cadeau c'est qu'on a
commencé à parler pognons ouh là là on
pourrait perdre de l'argent
bon ce que l'on fait nous voici à
carbone 4 de temps en temps en
connaissant très bien moi le premier les
limites de ce qu'on est en train de dire
mais il a rendu un cadeau empoisonné à
la cause parce que c'est pour ça on s'en
fout surtout que le Bau dans le même
temps c'est que le PIB double donc vous
perdez 6% d'un truc qui va doubler c'est
juste un nom sujet
terminé quoi
bonsoir petite question
et après il faut que je file
bonsoir
merci beaucoup pour cette conférence
alors ma mère ne voit remercie pas parce
que depuis que je vous connais elle
trouve que je suis très ronchon et
j'ai essayé de lui faire découvrir vos
vidéos et votre démonstration mais pour
elle il manque des solutions et s'il y a
pas solution il n'y a pas de problème
donc quelle est la solution à ce
problème ça repasse par les corps
intermédiaires c'est à dire que si je
cherche à convaincre un par un la
culture du consensus n'est pas
suffisamment forte en France pour que ça
fonctionne de reprendre le problème
totalement à la base il y a des pays
dans lesquels ça marche et les pays dans
lesquels ça marche c'est les pays qui
ont été qui sont issus récemment d'un
environnement qui est tellement hostile
que la culture du consensus chez eux
c'est là alors je vais vous donner deux
exemples vous allez voir tout de suite
c'est les Scandinaves et les Suisses
le Suisse avant guerre c'était le plus
pauvre habitant de l'Europe parce que
l'agriculture de montagne je peux vous
assurer que ça nourrit pas son homme et
donc le la tradition enfin je veux dire
la culture Suisse c'est celle d'un
univers terriblement contraint avec
l'hiver qu'il faut passer
avec les communications qui sont
difficiles avec etc et donc c'est à
cause de ça que cette culture là est une
culture du consensus ou en tout cas elle
est devenue moins avec la facilité
énergétique mais c'est resté un peuple
plus consensuel que nous donc chez eux
ils ont des systèmes de votation ça
marche bien etc pareil pour les
Scandinaves pop extrêmement consensuel
un peu pareil pour les insulaires que
vous prenez l'écorce ou les grands
bretons toutes ces cultures
d'environnement un peu hostiles voilà
plus vous allez vers le sud plus le pays
est grand et plus l'agriculture était
facile et moi c'est vrai donc l'Italie
c'est le bordel
en France la vie a été trop facile pour
que le consensus soit à notre portée
prenez un pays qui est de l'end of
Plantin No Limit c'est les États-Unis
alors là le consensus vous oubliez c'est
un truc qui n'existe pas chez eux ça
n'existera jamais
à cause de ce socle j'ai envie de dire
physique qui a bâti l'histoire des
peuples
en France le niveau j'y reviens auquel
vous pouvez taper pour commencer à créer
un embryon de consensus en fait un
embryon de rapport de force c'est les
corps intermédiaires donc votre mère
sera convaincu le jour où son patron si
elle a un boulot
son maire si elle l'aime bien ou je sais
pas quoi dis moi qui est passé 25 heures
à comprendre le problème je vais faire
ça
donc je vais embaucher les gens pour
faire ça il y a des gens qui feront pas
ça je vais leur demander de se former
pour faire ça je vais orienter le
système économique de telle sorte que
votre dépense quand vous achetez un truc
ça paye ça et ça paye pas autre chose
etc et là il achètera donc le et c'est
tous l'esprit d'un autre livre que je
n'ai pas écrit enfin juste après face
mais qui sort du shift project récemment
qui s'appelle décarbonon c'est facile de
s'en rappeler l'exclamation et c'est les
mesures qu'on propose pour organiser les
grandes filières qui composent
l'économie européenne pour qu'on avance
sur le sujet alors évidemment il faut
identifier les gagnants les perdants et
dans cette affaire tant que vous n'avez
pas traité les perdants vous avez nulle
part
il faut savoir traiter les perdants donc
il faut comprendre qui c'est et il faut
les traiter bien évidemment aussi il
faut pas prendre des mesures qui soient
accroissent le problème soit ne le
traite pas en France il y avait une
question sur la loi de transition
énergétique où est-ce qu'on en est bon
on en est le truc était bigorney de
travers depuis l'origine puisque c'est
occupé d'un objectif qui est à côté du
problème
voilà et je redis la mini-cola Hulot a
eu l'honnêteté alors que lui-même n'est
pas très favorable au nucléaire il a eu
l'honnêteté de dire là on est en train
de s'occuper d'un problème en étant en
train de s'occuper d'autres choses que
du problème climat et comme pour moi le
problème qui va passer un bon on va
commencer par s'occuper du problème qui
va
voilà ça c'est une position d'homme
d'État
avant avoir dit je vais tout faire en
même temps et je vais vous rendre le
monde merveilleux et tout ça avec nos
Costes du reste la dame l'a dit ça c'est
une position irresponsable
les gens qui sont en mesure de faire
comprendre que ça n'est pas une bonne
idée de prendre des positions
irresponsables c'est les gens qui sont
juste en dessous et la démocratie est en
scalèche je suis désolé de répondre
ainsi à la question sur l'humanisme il
faut faire appel je pense aux égoïsmes
bien compris des gens qui ont intérêt à
l'étage en dessous est-ce qu'on aille
dans la bonne direction collectivement
qu'est-ce que je crois
bonsoir
ça marche bonsoir merci beaucoup pour
cette exposé une fois de plus c'est
brillant
dans l'histoire de l'humanité vous vous
m'avez peut-être écouté trois fois moi
je l'ai sorti 500
dans l'histoire de l'humanité on a
est-ce qu'on sait un moment retrouvé
dans une situation parallèle enfin
similaire je veux dire où on a dû
anticiper un problème qu'on n'avait
jamais vu et il fallait trouver des
solutions pour y faire face et si c'est
pas identique au moins un peu un peu
près pareil pour et si et ce qu'elle a
été trouvé je suis pas historien donc je
ne saurais pas vous dire il y en a très
vraisemblablement des parallèles à des
échelles locales à l'échelle globale
jamais
il y a longtemps
et puis la réduction de population est
un peu drastique
[Applaudissements]